They'd be really careful. We don't talk
over each other because, um, you know,
it's fucking, it's hard not to. There's
six of us here. Yeah, Brian. All right.
We're live. We're live. You fucking
freaks. Ladies and gentleman,
this is an unprecedented podcast.
This is the first time we've ever
done an after the fact podcast.
Brendan Schaub and I know all the
Goddamn results. I honey else,
Brian knows one result. Yeah. Eddie knows
none. Robyn. I know. He knows a mom.
Yeah, the only one. So this is
beautiful. So no one's going to cheat a,
we're not gonna, we're not
gonna fix, but a, we decided,
we've got a bunch of people here.
Jimmy Burke's here.
Our friend Jimmy Burke from New York was
in town for Brian's birthday party last
night. Uh, Eddie Bravo was here. Of
course, Brian counts here. Brendan Schaub,
Robin Blacks and towns and
Robin blacks here. So, uh,
it's gonna be a lot of talking
over each other folks. Okay.
It's just deal with that.
Just deal with that.
We're going to watch the fights and uh,
and again also if you are expecting
any of us to like constantly watch the
fights only and not, that's not going to
happen either. So there's no rules. Okay.
Whatever expectations you have released
those or, or whatever, you know,
one of these or worrisome. All
right. Right now we're playing it.
We're going to start it and we recorded
it. So this is the first time we've,
we've got a recording and we're
going to watch the fights.
I'm going to fast forward to
when should I fast forward.
I should fast forward the
first fight, right? Yeah.
Really sit down at anyways, let's
watch the commercials. All that shit.
I'm excited about this,
but the problem is we can't really
play it out loud where we can hear on
podcasts. I know, but
that's what I'm saying.
So we might as well just fast
forward through all this nonsense.
This pregame bulls. Yeah.
It's kind of like porn.
So there's some good fights
in this fucking card. Um,
is good fights in actuality and
good fights on yes. Most of it all.
And Cowboy Dude. Yeah. Dude. Damn man.
Really does know the result. I
love it. I love the just, man.
I had to watch that fight. I just had
been out of the loop. I want to hear,
I can't wait for your breakdown.
Robin black. So here we go.
We're a fast forward through Jon
Anik and is super metro-sexual toss
that towel. Wow. Rock and
purple ties. Maybe it's um,
for in Omaj to Prince. So, uh,
we'll, we'll fast forward on cancer.
Yeah, why not, man? So
the first fight is uh,
Alex Caceres versus,
um,
what's homeboy's name that he fights?
He fights a dude from Alan Belcher's camp.
He's a wild man. Read Night Jason.
Nice Jason Nights. That's right.
He's fucking good. Yeah, he's very good.
And he's crazy and he's got to talk to,
he talks mad shit inside the octagon to,
he has his fight and he was screaming
at this dude going, come on man.
Take me down now. You want to take me
down? You want to stay on with me, bitch?
Yeah. He said, you don't want
to take now bitch. I was like
delirious. Hilarious. I came out
on the broadcast. Yeah, yeah.
Well I was laughing while it
was happening because, uh,
I was doing the commentary
and while I was going down,
not during this broadcast
was another broadcast.
This fight is with him and Alex Caceres.
So this is a,
uh, like a kind of a sleeper. A fight.
Yeah. Cool. Fight. All right, here we go.
Boom. All right, so for the folks at home,
what we'll do is when the first fight
starts, right now they're showing the, um,
a side by side comparisons, the heights
and weights and jazz, a tale of the tape.
And now Bruce buffer is doing
a little introduction here.
Why do they call it the tale of the tape?
It's been that for 50 years bikes,
somebody invented that. That was new
ones. Well, you know what's weird man?
How can they stop?
They stop measuring legs.
They measured legs for a little while
and then they stop measuring legs.
They were doing only weeks. Yeah,
did it for filtering and box.
And they measured late. We were always
complaining like with John Jones,
you're not fighting his arms. You're
finding his arms and his fucking legs.
And he's so tall.
Wall gun give is Joe Silva who asked
for leg reach I think. Yes. Yeah.
Joe asked for a lot of shit.
He's the,
he's the reason why a Mickey galls hey
Mickey, you're so fine. You're so fine.
You're right. That's how it got on the
uh, the broadcast because Dana White,
it was like,
fuck that.
You can't play that song for Mickey
Gallo when he fought cm punk, you know,
you know Dana so particular he goes
through all the walkout songs before cause
he loves music. He shot one of my walkout
songs down the night before the fight.
What was the song? It was a, I forget
in Brazil there's some cool song.
I thought it was cool. It's like a
dance song and I get a call in my, uh,
my coach was like, Hey, it's Dana.
Why might go shit, what's going on?
I'm letting you know bonus earlier some
cause I thought I was going to knock out
Nogueira out and like just give
it to me now. And he's like, hey,
that walkout sounds not happening.
Picks up the Nelson. I was like, wow,
this is, what did you pick?
A I m and m square dance.
Oh, okay. All right. Alex,
get Sarah's and Jason Knight
for 57 50 64554504453 all right.
Sync it up cause Sarah's the shelf on
the left hand, right. Get inside leg.
Bruce Leroy, you Harris is super
underrated. Him mean you gotta.
You gotta remember what Yaya Rodriguez
did to Bj Penn and then think of him and
[inaudible]. They essentially fought
to basically might've been a draw.
That's a style matchup, but don't you
think way for me with Bruce Leroy.
I like him. He's fun to watch. We still
hot and Cole. Yeah, he's on. He's off.
He's gone.
He's off.
Craig Jackson used Leroy for most of
the sparring rounds for Bj. No Kid.
He was his main spine guy and he
was doing great or great with them.
I actually thought Bj did very
well in the first two minutes.
The difference between what [inaudible]
does and Alex does is Alex is strikes
they the, they come and high volume,
interesting angles. He's very creative,
but they're not instantaneous and lethal.
The ear can fuck you up with one shot
and street kicker in MMA history.
You know what?
You got to send him,
you got to see him against a worldclass
moy targets. That's what you got to see.
Cause right now we don't
see him. No, no, no.
I'm seeing greatest of all time
and every now and then picks up
every now and then someone that's one
of those comfortable kicks every now and
then he'd lines multiple.
Every fight
jet leak kicks that he or his landing,
nobody else's landing chippy kicks.
He was doing that. J pen always fights
from a boxing distance in a lot of ways.
Who Styles Taylormade. He's
an older guy. He hasn't fun.
Two plus years before that, he got
work by Frankie Edgar. So you're,
you're talking about a Bj Penn has been
seriously out of the loop for a long
time and then he steps in there against
this fucking Bandolero do throw in three
60 round cakes.
I mean his style,
like it was almost like everything was
Taylor suited for Yahya Rodriguez for my
fighters and recommending I'm talking,
I told a couple of them they should
start just doing a local Sunday taekwondo
class once a week just to get the
spins tap, you know, it works.
We know it's effective.
Look, yeah, years proven it.
Every end of the main fighter out there
should be emulating Yahya. Yeah, I agree.
I think the days of coming out,
and of course I don't know
anything about striking,
but the days of coming out and just boxing
and throwing a leg kick every now and
then, I think that's, that's not
going to work. You're not gonna.
It's not gonna work against a
guy like Jon Jones Gregor. You,
you see these guys throwing all those
Taekwondo Kung Fu kicks successfully.
If you're an MMA fighter up there,
you coming up,
I think you should start taking
taekwondo now. That's a new point,
but I think if you watch glory,
there's a good fight that I talked
about recently because I got Joseph
Valtellina on it. Used to be good judge.
He's wicked, wicked kickboxing champion.
Really good guy too. But anyway,
he fought Raymond Daniels.
He's one of the best at
throwing those wild, crazy fun
Leroy. It's like a god man.
Me Means what?
What I'm Raymond Daniels did inside
the octagon or inside the glory ring.
He threw a flying side, kick touch
the dude and then spinning back,
kicked him in the air in the face.
Oh yeah.
Yo Raymond Daniels is a wild motherfucker.
But anyway,
Matrix Valtellina so you would see him
just doing the same kind of stuff that
Yahya Rodriguez does. He would say, oh
my God, if this guy gets in the UFC,
he's gonna fuck everybody up.
But Joseph optoline just chopped him down,
shopped in Beshar t pressure, really
strong physical guy, high guard,
super tight defense, and just kept
kicking the fuck out of his legs.
And then he finally head taekwondo
mix. No, I totally agree with you.
But I'm saying is we need to see a year
against a guy like a Niki hold skin or a
guy like, uh, like a
Joseph [inaudible] who's,
they have that super powerful
low kick fundamental game.
And we don't have a lot of guys that are
that strong at that inside the octagon.
Yeah. I'm sorry. Joe would mutilate them.
Val and he would just rip it now I MMA
they kickbox shows way larger than I am.
So it's not a good matchup. Technique
wise though. And fundamentals thoughts.
He's just on another level
when it comes to this. Kickbox
is leg. Yeah. Years. Yeah.
I'm really talking to kickbox
and we're only talking just
talking straight. Yeah, I get what
you're saying. But he's seeing it.
So when I get speech and speech,
but in MMA with an IBM taken down,
taken down,
you know what I mean?
So you could do wild shit and kickboxing
because there's no threat of getting
choked out. That's true. So I'm thinking,
but those guys are way better too.
They're way better at lake higher level.
The reason these things
in a real fight though,
that that's what I was saying
because he's doing it in a real site,
so he's better
taking it back.
Oh,
not enough time.
Oh, he's in great. He's
got enough time now.
He's pushing up on the Chin on the chin.
He should dance Evernham right there. Oh,
someone through a card in the
arts. Corsets. Dicks. Yeah,
so went through like a business card
in the octagon. I squared Daddy.
I think the reason you're seeing these
kicks work is cause guys weren't training
them.
If everybody's training the same shit,
you're supposed to do something different.
Everybody in the gym, the Training Jab,
cross, low kick, low kick, left hook.
They're doing all the same stuff.
If we all trained the same
stuff at our training,
partners train all the same stuff. We're
not prepared for different stuff too.
The thing is, yeah, you could
do the other shit too. Yes,
he's very good. He's very good at
scrambling. I think he's a pro bono,
but I think he's purple.
Rambling wrestling would be an issue,
but what I'm saying is
his Moitai is good too.
Like he's got a real strong leg kick
fundamentals. He throws good elbows.
He throws wild shit now
in that Bj Penn fight,
if they got in like an instant rematch,
like in another dimension, hopefully not.
But yeah. What would be
pulling guard might be, Oh
yes, because we already saw
shit. We took a glimpse.
He couldn't take them down with
straight rustling. Always try it.
First option should be tried to take him,
take him down with straight wrestling
passes, guard, get on top mount,
take us back. But if you can't take
the guy down and he's beaten you up,
stand, what else are
you going to do? Bj, Bj,
Bj got on him.
There's an art to pulling guard.
It's just like a take down but
don't just sit on your butt.
It's also a shoot deep enough to make
him sprawl and come up with a lot of Paul
Paul.
He shoots and then now you got something,
but what you're describing is different.
Again,
it's what not the norm of what everybody's
training and that's why it's a great
idea. I call it the third option.
In that case, pulling guard,
especially BJ's a world champion black
belt, he should have a guard. Crazy
taps. Anybody off of his back. BJ would
always sweep. God's always mountain,
take the back trying to pull guard,
sweep and get a shower.
It's just interesting that he never
tapped her on the numbers number.
Nogueira versus Tim Silvia get
swept them wanting to take him down.
Couldn't take him down. Tim was, was
fucking him up with that Long Jab.
What are Nogueira do?
He shot for a week as single and then
pull guard and we'll have time. Yeah.
Pull that off guard. Yeah.
Miguel Suarez. Anyway,
it was a trick he pulled and then he
did it again. Deep have sweet. Yep.
Got On top and guillotine. Yup. Miguel
Torres over and over with the Matrix.
Johnson. Yeah. People think pulling
guard, I mean is is uh, you bait.
It's like admitting you lost the war.
Eagles like committing suicide.
But if it was committing suicide for
real people, think pulling guard.
You're going, you're going
to get killed. Pulling guard.
How come it's so hard to do. How come
when Vinny Maga less sits on his ass?
People, his opponent got know you stand
up. Suicide. He's letting you get on town.
Awesome stuff, man. No, it's on top.
He broke that into two under hooks.
Hooks in. He go straight to the
body line and it's such a look like,
oh, the fence fucked them. Wow. I was
fuck he couldn't arch and sink it in.
That's a bad place to be.
Sub Two punches to sub to punch us to
sub to pile because it's a terrible
position to be in. We got fucking
body trying to squeezing down your Ab.
This guy is a specialist on that body
triangle and right here in the old days,
this would be over already
when they allowed pointed,
pointed elbows to the back
of the head dancer. Tap Acts.
We've talked about this so many times,
but I really do want to study on what
kind of damaged it happens when you elbow
someone in the back of the head and why
is it illegal to have to look at the
guys back in the battle. Caden,
remember John Lewis it to somebody?
He landed like three.
Does your taste strikers?
They're the judo guy. Yeah. Remember
that? I remember thinking, man,
that's going to kill the rear naked choke.
No one needs a rear naked choke.
Someone's post in it's old heavy hips.
Yeah. You don't need a rear naked choke.
Can you do elbow or no, just
open hand in. You're in the
same target is how are you going to stop
someone from that by following through
with that elbow. I know. I know
guys are finishing on the chin,
on the chin. You can't do with just
a straight cable over the chin.
If you sink it in deep.
Great defense by doing good like he is.
He's in the worst case scenario and
he's fighting and now he's got the law.
Don't you think that the hair,
like when it comes to gay
teens and things like that,
it's going to offer you just a touch
more friction and it's going to make it
harder to get out of stuff. Texture,
harder to get into. Yes. That too, right?
It's hair I get in the way of
sunchokes. I bet it would. Doris.
Right. By the way, speaking of the
hidden in the back of the head,
W I used to go somebody who got hit in
the back of the head and lost their taste
buds. He got hit once you can go
deaf. He could never taste together,
going to get hit with, with a punch
to the back of the head and he,
cause he's never taste
again. Eddie after. Uh,
so someone's body triangle in and
they take the other leg and extend.
You get the other foot underneath his leg.
Who's in a scenario?
I got the body lock here and this,
this other foot extending his foot.
The I'll show you right here.
Look over this foot. I've got the
body triangle. This foot here.
I've got behind this right here.
She hit him.
What's the bottom line of your,
yeah, that one. The white foot.
You'll see right there. Why is he hooking
that in there? Just sounded a control.
Oh he's just got them.
It's a matter of time.
That was too hard to keep
the level control leg.
This not under the knee extended legs.
You got the one leg that's controlling
and then that that instep is locked under.
Say if you got her on the right side,
you have the other one you
use as a butterfly and you
control the leg and if you
elevate his leg, it makes it way more
difficult for him to do one more step.
One more step he has to address.
Yeah. It's, it's also like
it takes away his mobility,
right? Yeah. Cause uh,
you want to get body triangle
in. Yeah. You want to have it on.
You want to have your opponent on his
side and you want the cinched park to be
on top. So he wants, he
wants it on the other side.
So That Butterfly Hook keeps your angle
like we're going to keep you right here
on the good side for me. Keeps you
where you want to be in right there.
You see that? Yeah. Yeah. Please do on
the wrong side here. But he doesn't care.
He's just, he's dealing with it cause it,
it puts a lot of pressure on your ankle.
It's not a good position to be. I
wonder if you could look, Eddie,
can you loosen up your ankle so
that that doesn't bother you?
Some people it doesn't. It
doesn't matter. It doesn't matter.
After you do it for a while, you
stretch your, it doesn't matter.
You want the cinch to be on top.
But if it's on bottom,
sometimes you switch it. But he's
like, I'm just going to leave it there.
It doesn't really matter. There's
trains out of belters camp that's, yeah,
I think he's about this.
This is thing that, um,
that ballerinas do where they shove
their foot into like this like big rubber
strap and you know,
your foot normally wants to sit
like this is big rubber strap.
We'll bend it down so that your foot
is parallel with your shin bone.
It's amazing what the human body would
react and respond to and adapt to.
Its an amazing,
but if you could get that going
on then the fucking body triangle,
it wouldn't bother you at all.
Somebody use that defense.
Why are we watching a geico
commercial fuck all that. So powerful.
Now the people at hallmark.
Yeah,
we want to tell him how to
sync it up on the next one.
So we're fast forwarding Jason night.
Let's see what he has to says.
They can fast forward. Yeah. He's
not afraid to say some shit. Jamie.
We have somebody down here anyway.
I think it's always fresh.
Guys. Don't call someone out.
Oh, whoever they want to give me.
I know you dedicate this fight to
oh Brian stayed with it.
Is Tim Tebow.
His Dad just passed.
Oh he did.
Thank you so much.
His birthday's tomorrow and I know.
Thank you so much man.
Just died last year.
Five days ago.
Short amount of time.
Is there anybody out there that's NBC,
Sir?
Did you see that fight with him and
he'd be asking for that.
It was the craziest fights.
Kennedy.
Remember that night your boy Kelvin
fucked up. That was us together.
Do Ho choice.
Cub Swanson having like one of the
craziest fights of all time of all times.
It's beautiful.
Fucking slobber knocker
nuts and who one cop?
Yeah. Yeah. It was like a full
on slobber knocker man. Some kid,
best athlete in the building fence
asked cheese chase best calf for him.
[inaudible] he talking about my
friend got him to animal birth. Funny
Christian Mccaffrey at all. There were a
part of us dies. They take all our women,
the handsome guy,
they stop.
That's why the athlete in college
football running back, son, that's real.
What's this deck as Macquarie Best?
That's the best running back in
college football. Flat fullback. God,
no tailback no second Heisman breakdown
on that next week on home and 43 I know
and it cool. That's not cool. Come on,
Trump's president and we got white
fucking rabbit. Kill it. Impossible.
I don't believe it's possible
with all the new vitamins
and kids since they were babies.
His Dad was an NFL pro,
so that's where he gets it.
This Holly Holm Germain de Randamie fight
is not an easy fight for Holly Holm.
People don't realize this
is a tough fight for that.
Germain de Randamie is
undefeated and Moitai. She's,
she's got some preposterous fucking record
and there's like 46 or something like
that. Nunez already beat her. Yeah, in
MMA, but it's a hobby. It's a kickboxer.
The thing about it is like Holly's gonna
Strike with her. It's going to be great.
It's a dangerous fight. Holly takes
it down. Yeah, she matched mine.
She has some good insight. Trotsky's
big athletics. Well, going back,
I'll do this one. You got three in her.
Oh God. Damn. How are we going to sell it?
She knows that. Isn't it
crazy? The support so quick.
No one stays. You weren't
following along. She was in there.
I never worked with shoes in there.
Great. Great Person. Freaking freak.
It's crazy how this fucking
sport just chews people up.
You think you're on top and
then it's gone and it's over,
but the casual fan doesn't care.
That's why that paper you his cell
because the casual fan goes, oh,
that's the girl who worked Ronda Rousey.
That's the argument for Mcgregor
versus Floyd mates. Fucking happening.
It's happening.
It's going to have to see. So Mcgregor,
it held a press conference last night.
Sold out arena. 5,000 tickets sold out
the on the Mikey was a fuck the UFC.
Fuck everything. He said, fuck boxing,
boxing and he goes, the next fight,
the next fight. Me Versus Floyd, he
was four. You get it, fucking done.
And then he goes, I'm going to
do it with or without the UFC.
And they told Dana that and he goes,
good luck with that.
Good luck getting that done without any
dead. He believes in with the Ali Act,
he can actually do it because
it's a different sport.
He has the money to hire the
lawyers to try it. Well it's,
it is an interesting argument
because it's not MMA boxing.
So if it's boxing it's not,
he doesn't have a conscious,
she should just promote it anyways and
work together with Floyd and say well but
it's not just with Floyd.
It's with McGregor promotions
now that he's got his own thing.
That's the key to promote
because they don't want it.
They don't want to have a third middleman
and Dana white cause you have Conor
McGregor promotions for me with it and
then the UFC and they don't want to give
the US Senate is going
to become what boxing is.
It's going to become that because it's
star driven like all things like music,
hey to comedy,
like everything.
It's going to stay star driven
and when it star driven like that,
guys like Connor who are legitimate stars,
they have the leverage and they're
going to manipulate that leverage.
They're going to utilize that leverage
and we're going to see what happened.
Especially right now, can just started.
We've ever had I a reality star driven,
but it is a reality. Why is
it, why do you hate that?
Because it's always been like
that in boxing. Well, right.
I mean that's how they make the
hundred million dollar paydays.
He's a purist and real
quick. Yeah, me too.
But I would love to see Conor was Floyd.
Rob, rob and I were talking about fights.
This dude said he's never seen a fight.
He doesn't lie. Every single fight.
I've hated a lot of fun. You'll
see Kimbo and Dada. Okay.
That you got right to it quick.
Right to the point.
That may be
some shitty fight,
fight, fight and he was like, I
liked it when guys are down on.
My stunt guys kept each other out there.
Gracie's last fight on Bella total
cable and we were talking about it.
I liked it too. This is what I
liked about that all bullshit aside.
How grace he fought a fucking killer.
I mean that guy knocked
out Joe Schilling twice.
You've knocked him out and kickboxing
and he knocked him out in MMA.
He's a fucking beast.
He's a very dangerous striker.
He's a very big guy
and he's fucking scary.
He's a blaster and how it
and did nothing. No, no, no.
He avoided getting knocked down.
I'm not talking about college.
I'm talking about your boy who's obese.
Didn't new math because he was scared.
He was scared to get strangled.
And what were you scared of is what
happened in the last minute of the last
round when Alex did take him
down past his garlic butter,
fucking mounted him and
had him in a bad spot.
Haluk was going to fuck him
up if that fight kept going,
if that was in the first
minute of the first round,
how might or fuel to do it?
If you hit the guy that was
entertaining your batch,
fuck, fuck, fuck.
And you hated Kim overs data that
was more entertaining than that.
I didn't hate him.
He was not a high level fight.
I hated the fact that people were watching
it on TV and both guys were severely
unconditioned. There were severely
out of shape like no, I didn't.
His heartbeat stopped. The hit to
true is that some of that is him,
but uh, no. I, when I think about it,
honestly I hated what the fight was about,
but I love to fight the dynamic of
what's happening between these two human
beings in combat. I mean dot.
On Kimbo. Yeah. Even that one,
the dynamic between them is
different than every other fight.
In their case it was Mike
because chosen Mike, Jamie,
there's my student out until the talk
was about, are you intrigued by the,
by the Conor Mcgregor Floyd Mayweather.
I said as if Conor McGregor could
actually box with Floyd Mayweather.
Mcgregor cannot box with Floyd Mayweather,
but Conor Mcgregor's what the only goal
that he could have the workable idea as
a backdoor hack. Something where being
unwilling to make it a boxing match.
He is fighting him with two hands.
But boxing is not the definition of
fighting with two hands. Find a hack,
find it back to her. What
would Tim Ferriss do if Tim,
if you said, hey Tim Ferris,
how, how'd he beat Floyd Mayweather with
a guy who has never pushed him off the
stand? You'd want someone else's
idea and regurgitate. Yeah.
Yeah. It's not that easy. No, it's not.
But Mcgregor has found
the disruptions. You, uh,
Uber is a disruption or Airbnb
is a disruption on the, on the,
on the hotel business.
Donald's trumps and disrupt using the
Tim Ferriss example of good reason why it
sucks.
It's because Tim did that whole show for
CNN where he did a bunch of different
things and learn quickly. And one of
them we tried to do is Jujitsu. Yeah.
Good luck with all that. Good luck.
Don't work like that. You know,
a guy who's been doing Jujitsu for 10
years can get drunk, stay up all night,
show up drunk and still play
with you like you're a baby.
He's name's Jon Jones and
Jon Jones. I Jon Jones, like,
I don't even think he's really
ranked in Jujitsu, all that.
He could tap black belts because it's
such a freak. But if John Jones wanted to,
he could do whatever he wanted. Yeah.
I mean, if they're the same size,
it doesn't matter. You can eat four months
is not going to get you there. But the,
the, the thought that I have is you
can't beat him in boxing. Right?
But what if you, there's some other
answer and the answer to that is, well,
and the hundred years we've seen
every answer, if you believe that,
if Mcgregor believes that he's fucked.
Well,
McQuaig rigor said that
was really interesting.
Yesterday in the press conference,
he said, look, if it was a fight,
it would be the easiest fight. Easy.
He goes, fuck UFC. Fuck boxing.
It's an actual fight. I'll fucking kill
him. It's a joke. He's right. He's right.
So we're going to limit it to hands
and you playing a little game. Okay,
let's do it. Yeah. And that's,
that's interesting there
because that plays to the ego.
And he's the only guy that could
ever say that to Floyd. No.
Floyd's everyone faced Floyd's ever,
never fasted guy. It says, listen,
this is not even a fight. This is
a boxing match. You want to fight,
I will fuck you up any day of the week.
Wake me up,
wake me up and say you want to do it, I'll
fucking kill you. Yeah. And that's true.
There's also quite a bit bigger, quite
in fast, and you have to be different.
If you go in and try to box him,
you have to strike with him in some way
that is different. What that answer is,
I don't know. Angles and the May gloves.
Well, people remember that Donna,
my Donna, who is super unconventional,
really wild and reckless.
My Donald was 12 rounds twice with a home,
you know?
And so Floyd is not knocking guys dead.
He's not like he's [inaudible]
Golovkin in people or Cov 11 people.
You know, it's a totally
different kind of experience.
What Ford does is minimize any offense
and maximize his potential to put offense
on you. And he's a genius at it. And
if, if his output super low is cause,
that's what he can get away with.
And if his output is super high,
it's because he's got you. Yup. You
know what I mean? He's a genius.
If Floyd Mayweather,
genius boxing genius. Yeah.
That's why you can't beat them and less
there's some answer that doesn't yet
exist that condoms aren't,
could go and then just do the
trucial box and sit in front.
And that's not people who think that it's
crazy other here's the other fucking x
factor and it's a real factor and
it happens in every goddamn sport.
Guys get old overnight and Floyd
Mayweather is 30 what? 39 years old now.
39 years old at 40 by the
time this fight happens,
I mean some guys it takes longer.
Some guys it's shorter.
Bernard Hopkins managed to get deep into
his forties and still be world class
and he hasn't taken much punishment.
That doesn't get hit. No,
I'll only really been tagged
by Mosley and my Donna.
Those are guys are really tagged them.
And then earlier in his career he got hit
a few times. Yup. Yeah. But mostly sat.
He, he, you know, he sat them down,
mostly wobbled and then one
shot dominated. Yup. Yeah. He's,
he's a genius. He really ingenious.
And if it go as it goes on,
if McGregor becomes predictive of,
so say this happens and he
becomes a predictable in any way,
even the ways that he doesn't understand
that flight will read and it just gets
worse as the fight goes on. He'll get
out. So somebody comes to you and says,
this is happening.
You're going to make $200 million for
whatever crazy amount of money you're
gonna make a, how do we do it? And
the answer is you have to be very,
very different. You have to move
away from, from Floyd for sure.
You have to move away from him and draw
him in and you gotta be different almost
every round. You've got to have a
strategy that makes you unpredictable.
And even then you have to
hit somebody who's never hit.
So what I'm saying it and boy tied dumps,
I'm saying anything.
He ties him up fucking leg.
Let's give them something to think about.
Touching the ground
rules. Definitely. If he could,
you know, just one or two times.
If they get in the clinch and there's
some shit talking [inaudible] he just
decides to dump them and you see
Floyd's feet go flying up in the air.
Why is a small man choice?
What would you rather see them and it
just a straight boxing match with boxing
gloves or a boxing match with MMA glove
would want to do a boxing class all
day to make gloves or the big love.
He would want the big lifts
account events for default,
which is very important because it's
really hard to get because like it's a
whole different game when you're
getting around those little gloves.
Pink Floyd to go damn. What the Middle
Ground Dan's, his hands break a lot.
Great Tire lifetime. You have developed
your style around the size of the Mitt.
Yeah. You can't change your
front gate. I can sit, hey Floyd,
Connor's given up so
goddamn much get thrown
in the business. They given
you any so weird though.
Get an MMA best boxer.
Everything about his experience and his
sensitivity is around his whole lifetime
being built with this exact thing.
Sometimes he catches things in small
little details and another factor is the
speed of the incoming shots.
It's going to be much faster when
you're dealing with four ounce gold.
There's guys in worldclass boxing,
they're fast as fuck, right,
but they'd be faster if they have four
ounce gloves on it. It's just a fact.
It's just a fact of physics and he,
that speed almost might be
indistinguishable to us,
but to a fighter it might
be the difference between
getting hit by something and
not getting hit by something and you would
have to re gauge your distance meter.
Yeah. Different pitchers throwing
different speed balls. Every hitter,
this mother fucker and Ghana, no man.
I've been calling his fights for awhile.
When that guy walks into the cage,
it sounds different.
She is hand next to stands to the 56 dude.
He makes me look a little tiny person
and he can keep it in his pocket.
He's huge, man. He's
not small. No, no, no.
He's a big dude and he's just
solid as a rock man. He's,
he's French. He's French.
Oh, Nigeria. Yeah.
And he's just a super athlete man.
They think he's the next strike
the next big thing. Well, you know,
we've yet to see him against a really good
wrestler. We've yet to, I wouldn't eat,
I don't say anybody's next week
thing until they go with Kane.
You gotta go again. Healthy
came pressure. Travis,
you see what he did to Rothwell?
He just does.
He gets his face and your chest and just
when he gets past all your bullshit and
then puts it to you with a
pace that you just can't take.
The real question with Kane is, can he
still do that? He's had so many injuries.
They pulled him off of his last
fight because he's got stenosis,
so it's fucking spinal column is shrinking
and they have to open them up and say,
no, no nerve steep pavers. JDS. Now
that is what the next step of fighters,
steep pace. Legit. That's
real. I know. Who wins now,
Steve Bay jds because ain't nothing.
You'd like to see him fight
again? Hosanna. Hosanna,
quack, quack, quack, quack. I
don't want to, I know hands please.
One thing about me is I take my MMA. I
would, I would have said the same thing.
You like MMA? I do, Dude.
It's like secret garden.
I said, well, I'm a combat. I'm a combat.
Well, I'm a sportsman as you guys know,
and I like to get up close and personal
and impose my will on another man in
Gannon was feet looked different too.
They like thicker. Like his heels.
Is he six five giant, giant.
When Randy Randy fought
Brock Lesnar,
he said that the distance
was hard to gauge because
this proportion was so weird.
So you can't actually,
he's got an enormous reach.
And when your body shape is different
like that, it tricks the eye. The way,
when you look down the Strip in Vegas,
you can't tell how close and
far away those hotels are. Yeah.
The God that looks way bigger than
Mr Alaska who's good to 40 well,
the thing about in Ghana, who
is, he's a natural size to like,
that's a big gentlemen. God is. That's
just who he is. He's a giant dude shop.
You fuck guys this big. I thought you just
said shop. Have you fucked us? He did.
Answer is yes. Yes, yes.
When? When? Necessary.
Only to correct that. That's only
when it rains. No Man. Our lost keys.
Only 37 isn't that crazy? That's a lot
of my, maybe years at tortoise though,
but that's crazy because inboxes,
but he's got a right there.
He's, he's running at him
and throwing punches too,
but he comes in behind that
double right hand all the time.
You can see it coming now. Yeah. He
looks scary. It's foot work. Yeah.
He is very much improved.
He wants to teach.
Trying to draw him forward. Imagine him
with, yeah. Your style kicking. Well,
he's awesome. No, that's
common. Spooky. Yikes.
Protect them. There was had overhead.
Our Lawsky with the overhand right.
He had just twice the Debra cuts.
What did him in,
I think our last lives you read
our laps gets overhead, right.
As soon as that overhand right is there.
This has done to tell him to stop with
the lightening bolts in the hair. Do.
Should we do it now? Should we do it
online? How it is in France though.
Weird shit and he's
just dominating bitches.
So I watch it when we see the replay.
Our he's overhand, right? Was the,
was the towel.
He called it too.
He said he's going to knock them out
on the first round. Is that a lot?
Press Steven then?
Well the last time is for Travis Brown.
I mean you gotta think are lost.
You just knocked out Travis
Brown a couple of fights ago.
He's lost his last three though.
Now you can watch the right hand off of
our loss. Keith, the overhand right there.
Now you got them cause you know
what it is. Boom right behind me.
Look where it's head position.
Head position is,
he knew exactly what was coming and he
lifted him off the ground with that upper
core
physician that is fucking view to fall.
He planned,
he knew it was coming
with the overhand rights.
Conor Mcgregor Shit actually Nate Diaz
does that. The Diaz brothers to that slip,
they use their right hand, the
front hand. Once the front end,
the Diaz brothers throw that
hook from from south like that.
It's almost like a check. Yeah.
You draw a slide out. It's a head
position is key.
And then he'd come back over top.
Isn't that was by design so important
that a referee know how hard a guy hits.
Yeah. Because no one's complaining about
that. Stop it. No. But in other fights,
that would have been a stoppage
where people were and what the fuck?
You only took a couple shots,
but he's down.
Give him a chance to recover and not
with the Datto you like. No, no, no.
That's good. That's good. It's good.
Yeah. Probably hear the impact. Oh yeah,
for sure. See him fight like a Rothwell
where that shot doesn't put them down.
He just keeps coming through a little
beard and like put square that one time
and stuff. That's, that's the, maybe
it does. We don't know because he's,
he's beat up basically cans.
Thank. Give him our Lawsky right.
And just merge here
now. Well, you remember,
do you remember when Ben Rothwell fought
Arlovski and I lost you fucked him up.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean that was our
labs scheme when he was in his,
well not even in his prime. He was a
little slipped. That's the fiction.
It was a little past his prime.
Yeah. You know I lost keys.
Prime was when he was in his twenties
he went on a Rah Rah run in the UFC one
fight away from a heavyweight title
match. What, two years ago? Two years ago,
but do you remember when he was young?
I remember when he starts Paul Bunch
off one punch. He's my favorite.
He had a right hand that was like a piston
dude and it's almost like now you can
see the wear and tear on his
shoulders when he's throwing punches,
like he throws punches differently now.
Back then everything was just
laser beam straight. Remember,
remember when you went to wildcard and
was just working with Freddie Roach and
tall and just getting knocked the
fuck out left? Well, not to Jackson,
but he was doing well after a freight
train with Freddie Roach who is doing
really well against fader or,
and then he just, he panicked.
He was lighting him up. He was doing well
and they did a flying knee and failed.
I was like,
what the fuck man?
Best timing in the game with his right
hand. Like it was just deceptive.
How about Israel coming up in like
two weeks, right on spike. Yeah.
That's weird. I just feel bummed out that
we never got to see fade or in the UFC.
I still feel, feel, feel
bummed out. There's up.
There's an empty hole in my heart
for that one is not at his best idea.
It'd be cool to see him, you know,
passion melded. Dano fight that he had.
Yes.
Maldonado fucked him up.
I watched that like this and it'll
make you sick to your stomach.
Should have got the you, Oh, you know
the commission turned it. Yeah, they did.
I think to a no contest and look that
up Jamie. I might be batshit crazy.
I think they switched it to only one side.
He got a no contest. Russia was like,
all right. Yeah, we fucked up. Wow.
That's when you know you
got jobbed Russia, Russia.
They're like enough. Wow. This guy.
But you know that when you heard
school like our Lawsky did,
they're like these young guys.
You guys can just talk to each other.
Put your headphones on. Brian Cowen,
you're on the microphone is a podcast.
We've talked about this before.
You son of a bitch. Does he cough?
What does he call me without here?
Does does friends. Connie went out
now man, I ain't even heard it.
Zero English haunting. You
hate American dollars. Cranky.
Look. Yeah. Fatal Arts
victory over time. This
girl,
he's trying.
Sorry.
Oh that's not bad at all.
Good for him man.
You're giving me some Nice Alon
Soufriere more former job and then
I'm very happy to win the fight.
He's saying he wants big fights. I'm
very [inaudible]. Me a former champ.
I'm a believer in a mouth that was
pure scale of this position coming off.
Yeah, draw, draw back and
where your head is in space.
It's just the one and he'd take it
off the shoulder did. He's terrifying.
He is the most terrifying
heading in a long time.
Read that Shit coming from 20 miles away
and the right hand combo is part of it.
So it's a, it's designed
to play wrestling, I guess.
His wrestling's pretty BC. They say,
you know, granted it's the French,
but he trains with the Olympic wrestling
team and he can't get his ass down.
Well also the judo team,
he's, they're bringing in all
sorts of really high level.
Yeah.
The size of his hands.
They're saying they're bringing in a
bunch of different Olympic level athletes
to work with this guy. I mean
he's a real prospect, prospect.
Prospect in a long time.
Skeptical.
Hippalands I'm not a believer
after knocked him out.
That was a skill when that was
designed, play off and overhand. Right.
Planned shot up and it's right there
and look at him every shot. A shot.
All right. Twitter. Prazole let's see.
I think people are crazy. Dad. One Point
Pena was the favorite. It's like, dude,
dude, the oddsmakers not, I don't know
who the fuck mate. Those on for a while.
Then the, the public was like, what the
fuck? And we're going to get money on it.
And then the favorite.
Nothing against Pena,
but you're looking at somebody
with 400 fights. Check, check,
got crazy fight.
She's got haunted bus,
kickboxing and boxing. Hundreds
of fights. She's so hard.
Dude just said,
Jack goes so hard to turn
down like a hard person.
She's a hard woman.
She's just rushing chick who loves guns.
I mean her nickname is bullet.
She has a contract to on her hip.
She has a
skill versus hard in this fight. Oh,
you guys are already told me one.
I haven't seen this fight.
You're going to love this fight.
This fight is going to be interested
by two desks. Bermudez coming up.
It's going to fight Korean
Zombie, dude. No, no, no, no.
Next weekend if I fucking
pulled out and see what
the fuck is going on.
The fifth fight fight that got canceled
for eating. Something's going on.
But the good news is, is two weeks for
the fight he might get a replacement,
so we'll see what they have to
find someone. Maybe it's hard, man.
Flyways it's not easy.
It's not easy to find a good flyway goods.
A different answer. Maybe there's some
young dude who's just waiting bike,
you know, waiting out
there. I'm sure there is.
If he get along as he can
make the weight man, you know,
like because New York isn't it? They
don't fuck around with riots in New York.
Yeah. If you fuck up with, uh,
the, the weight in New York,
like if you're over by a think it's
eight pounds, they won't let you fight.
That's fantastic. But, and
one of the cards that is fair,
I heard that it happened on one of
the cards. It was kind. That's right.
That's right. That's right.
That's why they pulled him.
Yeah. Yeah. Tim Kennedy. Yeah,
that's right. And Goddamn, he
erased everybody's anger about that.
Everybody was so mad about that destroy.
He's worried.
He's one of the guys that had a
taekwondo talk with and he goes, dude,
he pulls out video of this training
because I'm already doing this.
He had like a session where he's spinning
and just getting all that spins down.
He's on it.
Get them on that nutritionist son.
I think I want any five [inaudible] five.
He's fighting veto any lots of good,
funny to Woodley and just split
decision and he was exhausted as my guy,
Ron hit mass. Phenomenal.
He was he, I think 17 sorry,
but he was drained for
that fight. You know, he,
he'd cut a ton of weight for that fight.
I don't like him at 70 I liked them at
85 you like your chance to become world
champion? 85 I think he could do it. I
think he just has to gain some muscle.
Nine he's Lik you said,
put on some mass or figure out a way
to comfortably make one 70 and a much
healthier way for, he's not
draining himself. He can be champ.
He can be champ at one 70 the road
to one seventies easier. Oh look.
Everybody gets tired,
but he doesn't get tired.
That dude is still pumping
it out in the third round.
And when he was overwhelming
Kennedy and the third,
was it a second or third round? When
both smashed them second. Right.
Did you stop him in the
second or the third?
But it was just a second pace was
out of control. His footwork is,
but that's what I thought.
The big factor.
I thought there's two big
factors in that fight.
I thought one kit Tim is a big one,
any five, and he's super strong.
It's Jujitsu's real good.
If he gets Kelvin down,
he might be able to blanket
him and beat him up.
But when he started getting tired,
I was like,
he's going to have a real hard time
with Kelvin's footwork cause Kelvin's
footwork. He's nasty, he's real lie.
He bounces around and
he does a lot of faints.
He's not predictable and he
comes in behind that Long
Right Jab, he fucks you up,
man. He's a southpaw. Sneaky South Bach.
He comes up with his right jab sometimes.
Sometimes he comes in, he hooks you,
he digs. The body has grapplings good.
His Chin is made out of fucking granted.
He's a killer. Can Be tough to be,
have to.
Super Cool.
Just sweetheart of a guy after he made
Kevin Swanson versus joy with him and he
was just having the time of his life.
He was not touched,
but I've talked to him rough night
for Tim puts in, made a big mistake.
He went from one camp straight into the
other camp and apparently he was very
flat and they were saying that he was
definitely overtrained like he just drove
the chain. I just one foot in,
one foot out to these guys, got
to these new,
these new gen guys.
They just understand the space between
you better like they manipulate the space
between you and we just saw
it within Ghana, you know,
he just has a better understanding of the
space between you and his opponent and
how to use as the stand and bang phase.
That's shit's done.
That Standard Bank phase is done.
Yes. At a world class level,
standing bangs done and everybody
wants to be world class.
When you see guys like Conor
McGregor raising their fucking bar,
the new ones coming up
like the Eir Rodriguez,
like the fucking Cody Garbrandt who can
be next level and what are they doing?
They're moving like a mother starts
control moves. No Stan and bang.
It's calculated. Exchange is
calculated risk worldclass technique.
Everybody's accelerated,
everything is way higher and higher level
and then they're at this new level and
they're accelerating in their ability
to improve from that level. So it's,
it's like exponential and it's weird.
And then young guys coming up,
I commentated some fights between,
I was telling Brendan and 18 year old
named Tony Laramie and a 20 year old named
Keith Lee, Kevin Liezel,
a brother from Vegas,
they were both all window and
it was some high level shit,
high level,
the way that they played at distance
of the way that they manipulated the,
the timing. It was fucking crazy,
uh, for Tko for a fight pass.
But Canada is getting,
nothing is accelerating faster
than high level MMA right now.
If you go back 20 years ago
and look at a word is today,
there's not a sport in the world.
We see that much of a jump between 20
years ago and today new technology,
it's moving like technology. It's
evolving like exactly. The question is,
when are we going to see
a guy who kicks like yeah,
year and also has Joe Schilling style,
Moy Thai, and also can box like Cody,
10 years olds right now that
are bull lowing your mind.
And that's why when you
see a guy like yeah,
year and you see this next level
expression, you realize like, wow,
the horizon is going to be bananas.
We're going to see guys like, yeah,
you're fighting another guy like guy here
and we're just going to see chaos and
the level of performance, just their
abilities psychologically to fight.
And that's growing exponentially.
They're honors raising that
individually by himself. Yeah.
He's raising everyone's expectations
for how someone performs under pressure.
He steps in there against Josie Aldo
and fucking sleeps in 13 seconds and a
fight that he's been talking shit
about for a year for a straight,
solid year world tour talent.
Everybody's gonna fuck him up.
And he goes and starches him with one
punch in exactly the way that you knew if
he was going to do it drawing.
And that was a punch you had seen him
use and that strike he'd been using since
England in England and
Ireland before he ever,
he was landing that in
space drawing you forward.
It's one of my favorite tweets ever that
I tweeted him in like 2013 as I'm a big
fan. I hope you get into
the UFC one day. Boom.
What fight in tweeted back was
it that got you into a man?
I watched a bunch of
his fights from England,
but it was a one fight
where he slid back and Kayo
this dude with his perfectly placed
lefthand. Yeah. And I was like,
this kid's got some fucking timing.
And the like for as a hobby
describes the touch of death. Yep.
Yup. No, when you got that kind of power,
you can see his body is built to
deliver that power, but it's technique.
It's clean.
It's awesome
thought. You know, he's, he's very, uh,
the way he's approaching
the game is very thoughtful.
He's thinking it through like getting
down with Ido port and just concentrating
on the ability to move your body
better. Yup. Just all you know,
across the board having
that kind of dexterity,
thank better, better movement. Absolutely.
No you haven't. You're sticking with
that. I think it's all bullshit.
It's definitely not. Definitely
not bullshit. Bullshit.
I don't think it's bullshit.
I think it can help you,
but you better have the foundation in
the skills of common Gregor before you
bring in a coach like that.
You cut other shit out.
Just talking about doing movement stuff.
I think it's very important
like gymnastic, gnostic,
not you're all the way those Brazilians
kicking at your head. That's real shit.
I see it in break dancing,
breakdancing as movement at the ultimate
movement drills and I see it personally
in Jujitsu.
All those guys from the freak show,
they all did you Jitsu and al got really
good, really quick. So it, yeah, it does
for the uninitiated is Richie and
Geo Martinez down in San Diego.
They're bad motherfuckers who are badass
break dancers who have turned into
Jujitsu,
black belts who are out there marketing
people and they told me about it when
these guys were white belts. He
told me about it. He's like, dude,
I've got these new guys are white
belts and they're phenomenal.
Like everybody knew it like right
away that they have this very huge,
very unusual ability. And you know what
man, you got to give it up to the band,
Hicks and Gracie cause he
figured it out before anybody.
You go back to those 1994
Hixon Gracie videos were,
Hickson was in Santa Monica
standing on a balanced bar,
stretching his leg overhead in a full
split. He was doing the rings. He was,
he was walking on his hands. He was
doing all those breathing exercises.
He was down with Yoga and movement and
dexterity and flexibility before anybody.
By the way, this is my new favorite ball
time commercial is fucking commercial.
Back this up a little bit.
This is Jamie gimme gimme some knowledge
or give me some, uh, some volume.
There's north haven [inaudible] second.
I lost the Kelly Clarkson.
There's a
tiny horse guy or get these ranchers.
He's got red hair.
Purple issue is you deserve this.
This was kind of,
commercials have gotten
crazier and crazier because
they have to cut through the
buck.
Buckaroos.
It's a tiny little dude who's flamboyantly
gay on a tiny little Wah Whitehorse.
He's got that. That's probably the third
one. That was the funny thing. Yeah.
I got a gay as fuck buyer. It was
awesome. Not how that's not true.
Got a private prince guy. Yeah, you
might be. You might be right. Yeah.
It fucks small girl like tiny.
You never know, but it's great.
Great God damn commercial.
Anyway,
we'll fast forward to the shit
and get to the cowboy fight.
This fight is a fight that I felt
coming into this fight and give it away.
I'm not going to get,
I'm not going to give anything away
from saying coming into this fight.
I think that a lot of people don't
know how good Jorge Mas for dollars.
So this is not a fight that
that many people are cause
he's scared, but no, no, no.
You can't do that, man. I want to
give him shit away. Yeah. Real,
super, super dangerous. So cowboy,
a lot of people would think this fight
wouldn't be as close as it's likely to be
stopped.
That
cowboy at one 70 is so much better than
cowboy 55 and he's one more example of
just like we talking about with Calvin
guys who don't cut weight and because of
that they look healthier. They're
like faster, like stronger.
They just think of more durable to,
they can, they can recover from stuff.
But the trade off of course is
at one 70 you know he's fighting.
If you fight like Tyron Woodley,
you fight,
you know you're finding someone hits
way fucking Harvey Lawler. Yeah.
Way fucking harder than anybody.
If 55 this guy is.
So it's really getting these skilled max.
He's relaxed instead of breakdown on him.
And I put in some of his
old backyard fights. Yeah.
But he used to have those backyard
fights back in the old Kimbo days.
Kimbo was in this corner for
[inaudible] bad mother fucker.
I can do that for a while.
It's got some knee issues.
So it's had some knee
issues for a long time. Man,
he's been hesitant usually
and a lot of his fights,
he always tends to always fucked up,
man. His knees are always fucked up.
He's trying to intimidate cowboy cause
everybody thinks that if you intimidate
cowboy to work in the Matt Brown fight.
No.
See everyone thinks that Matt Brown fight
was like a cake walk. That was a bit,
it's a bit of a flight. No, it
was definitely not a cakewalk.
Matt Brown and a cakewalk. No, no.
I'm saying people think cowboy.
I didn't think Kalbi look
that great in that fight.
I thought it was so real good.
Fight is a fight he looks at at all,
but he's fighting Matt fucking Brown.
Matt Brown is a Goddamn Barbarian.
He's a bar band. He lost what?
Five is less six. He's about Bam.
Take account shots then number 12
guy cause he doesn't give a fuck.
He wants to Denver.
He just knocked on Matt Brown six weeks
ago and he's like I want to fight in
Denver. Denver's his hometown. He did take
some punishment in that fight. He did.
He definitely took some punishment
and that Matt Brown fight,
but this is what he loves to do man.
He loves to just get back after it and
he loves that story. He loves. He also,
the more he fights, the more comfortable
he is fighting. You know, like it more,
it becomes natural. He went to a concert
last night, the night before this
steel Mexico to Mexico in like the
middle of his campus and near the end.
Yeah, let's do that. I don't
know. He says it relaxes
him. I guess he did at one camp
in it. He had a great performance.
So he said that it relaxes. If your last
week is just sweating a lot anyways,
you can do it anywhere and
he does have to make weight.
He fights at one 75.
I mean he walks around at one 75 one
76 he's not cutting anything. No,
he looks great at something. He
can be. We'll shape it up at all.
Yeah, I agree. Uh, people
sinked up to this. Oh yeah.
Four 40 74464405444 first round.
Thank you.
Thank you. Right? Yeah. This
is a real interesting, Ooh,
good stepping round kick to the body and
they'll switch kicks of his and nasty.
Yes. He's so good with
it. And he's also good,
like sneaking it up high out of nowhere,
which is what he did with Matt Brown.
He snuck that a switch
kick off the left leg.
That was a front leg
round kick to the face.
He knocked Matt Brown out with different,
their rhythms are,
I see it as conflicting rhythms.
Well,
Mosbey doll is much more boxing
oriented in his, uh, his attack.
See, he's letting them know he's
trying to play on that a little bit.
You don't hear it. I have
watched this fight. You don't
hear it, but he's like, Ooh,
Ooh. Like is making sounds. He's trying
to give a cowboy novel experiences.
See, you can see is he is making
some noise. That's interesting.
I wonder if we would get pulled if
we had the sound in the background.
What would happen? Young Jamie Foxx.
Jack. Yes. It's Fox with Jack mean. Oh,
Fox Tel Fox. I'll come back.
I'll do a couple shows. Yeah,
that might do it. Just let me, let me
talk some shit about one or two of them.
Oh, right hand and a left turn.
It was so good. A mass mass,
all wants to stay in there long enough
to land the last punch and backed Donald
up. And that's hard. He's
super tough hospital.
So tough to get Donald go back leg
thereby mosfet all is well.
He comes in and clean with that jab
and he also has a real nice high guard
mosque. Ooh, he's, he's a
crafty fire man. Really?
Well-Schooled so smooth.
Like I like that inside leg
kick Donald throws me two dogs,
one of the best leg kickers in the,
in the sport for sure.
And Jorge has taken him. Dad's
here. It's like the hands. Oh,
not too worried about getting taken down.
He's so tall.
Like you fight scarring on his,
but when he engages in another strike,
like he probably has a, one of the most
head kicks to him and he's laughing.
Yeah.
Oh for sure.
He said he wants to be in there
till the end balls leg though.
Calvin eating that shit. Beautiful inside
leg kick there. Yeah. Oh I love that.
Little off time. Body fat. Oh,
we went to the bottom of there to
look at my dog eats it and comes back.
That was the question, right?
With the leg kicks. Well,
how's he going to deal with it?
We Sat,
he would counter off
them with punches and I,
his counters off the kicks are slightly
different to instead of sweeping the one
side and they're now using the typical
cat off that he'll go left hawk,
but he also just takes it. Yeah, he's
so aggressive. Tough. Yeah. It was so,
he's so like a,
the fact that he keeps closing
the distance in on cowboy
people don't understand
honestly walking down.
Yeah. No, he's very good.
Don't never have that breakout
when I don't mean to interrupt you.
You know what I'm saying?
Like he's never had that huge staple.
If you look at his lifestyle too,
I mean,
he really has had to concentrate and be
much more dedicated over the last couple
of years because before he used to play
a lot of video games and fuck off and
you know he was, yeah. It was like half
of the fun of watching his downtown.
I love that little food
to come forward that yeah.
Donald was to take time to got
good takedown defense, man.
That American top team is a fucking oh
yeah. Little bit. Yeah,
a little bit. Yeah. Yeah.
You could see he's backing up a
little man, that Spinning Elbow,
but the jab is just nice.
That's switch kick off the left side.
That Donald throws is
so nice. Add, subtract.
Jorge's hands are down and they're knocked
down tonight. Man. He know he dead.
Serious lot of respect.
Just understands what it is.
Completely on that right side because
of that left high kick left hiking. Ooh,
he's throwing overhand competitor.
Arlovski's it's hidden. Yeah.
Yeah. This is just expressed.
It's not throwing. Honestly,
when I look at her labs can move. I've
got to go back to this. Ooh, Nice.
I feel like our lab skis
shoulders are calm. Yeah.
Probably a lot of where I really tight.
He's throwing punches like he's throwing
him with his arms and jaw could only
take so many punches. Right. There's that.
Everyone's got a certain amount that
they're going to take and that's his check
who you tell him. Well, not
only that dude, when guys
take, oh, nice leg kick there.
When guys take a lot of
punishment, they're fucking
motor skills start going, bro.
Like they don't, they can't them up the
same way. That's her right there. Oh,
he got tagged there again. That runs about
starting to get loose. Oh Geez. Gotcha.
I always heard that. That hurt me.
He got flat footed there. Yeah.
It's all push and push Paul
or hey. Oh, strong kick.
Take size on medicine.
Yep. Oh, he's out there.
He's out. That fights that, that
fight. All right. Nope. Nope. Nope.
End of the round and the round that's
fucking out. When have you, Joe, what?
Have you ever seen a rubber,
whenever you ever seen a ref at the
end of the round go like this? Yeah.
Like gets out. He might a
question himself. Mm. Yeah.
It's better off to just fight now.
Call. They should have it right there.
She ended the fight right there.
He looks out right there.
Once that calls over,
now it's up to the doctor and Greg's
just going to do his job here. He hadn't,
what Jackson is, was screaming at him,
you're not going to lose in Denver.
This is what I want for you head movement.
What are you going to do? Move my head.
You know, and that there, there was
a big pep talk here, but honestly,
you've got to wonder whether or not
it's the right move to send a guy out.
You don't know.
I mean you're
hopeful. You want them to recover. You
don't want them to lose by stoppage.
Let's take a look at it here.
Off the left to the boom and the right,
the top of the left hand behind it.
Let's, so he's in deep trouble here.
He's out there, he's taking shots,
his eyes rolled back. Watch this,
left her steps in.
Who kicked it?
He knew the kick was coming cause he
kicked the body. Boom, boom, boom man.
What a combination. Sam, Bam,
Bam, Bam, Bam. He sweeps,
he sweeps the kick away
and it loads his left talk.
Now do you feel that curb was stopping
the fight and then the bell rang and then
he said, let's just keep it going. That's
the doc. I don't think he should be.
It's on the dock.
I think it's not.
It shouldn't be on the corner so much
or the fight of the fire's going to want
to fight. We can't do this hard.
I smiled at him. I got you.
What do you think the people would want?
They want blood.
They don't give a fuck if
Kelly got over right there.
A definitive that money on it. If you
have money on Mazda, you want that shit.
Fuck all those people though. Fuck
those. Exactly. Think about the fighter.
See Donald be a world champion.
Wants him to take brain damage and
it's what's right. You know what is,
what is the right thing to do?
So right now it's very hard to argue.
That's the wrong thing to let them
fight because he's moving around and his
hands are up.
No compromise.
You have to protect the fact again,
when I was fucking him up, man,
oh my God. See Kelly jumped at garbage.
Tough. Goddamn. He got fucked up there.
He's inviting the kick, kicking him to
try to get them to kick him to kick back.
Don't kick the knee. He is. Oh, nice
kick. He's asking for Keck. Yeah.
Did you see the way Donald's throwing
those punches? Those are purely defensive.
He's just trying to keep him off and
then he goes for the cat home and tagged
them again.
That's the end.
You feel shop so tough
shots and that's it.
Yeah, just stop. It's a bummer for
cowboy, man. That's a fucking bummer.
He goes, you know what happened? Did he
just say, you know what would happen?
Fuck you.
Say you know what happened?
You know what happened then
when he said to him, yeah,
he's a kid and they talked a lot of shit.
And then when you mark the guy in his
own town, it's like, yeah, what's up man?
Fucking told you that talk.
There's interesting,
he's got those shells and the pink shirt.
Yeah, the doctor and he swears degree.
Easy. Easy on the hands. I know that guy.
He's very, he's doctor. He's just shocked
to see what he says here. Look at this.
You know what happens? You
know what happened? Hold on,
give me some volume, Jamie.
You it happened real
dark. Fuck that. Lose it.
Lose that with a little
more gray is he beat Donald,
talked to all that shit and then
when that happens and the guy goes,
I fucking told you. Everyone goes,
oh, sore loser. It's a fight, man.
He's cool,
nasty.
And he just backed up. He's like, I
fucking told you that was going to happen.
Maslow asked for this fight. He
was, I will fuck him up in Denver.
He can be to anybody. He
literally can be. Then if he's on,
if he brings his end game,
he can cause this fight was made
after cowboys glass win, right?
Mostly they'll say, I'll fight him
and then cowboy boots on Michael's.
Let's do this dance in Denver.
Sweets after fucking getting dropped by
Matt Brown, you got to protect myself.
Watch how he launched the lefthand
right there below. It's tough for him.
He loves it. I left high school and
this is a stoppage. This is the end.
Got very fast. He got a one.
Most of it all is a monster.
You gotta wonder it was the right call
to let them come out for that second
round. Loaded hip. Yeah, right.
There we go. Good action.
I know why they let it go. I want to see
more action. I as a coach though, Eddie,
you shit. If that was Tony first
names, you shouldn't be saying
you're a coach in real life
though. I want to see anyway.
Mother Teresa,
look at this for a second.
You'll see was Tony or Kelvin you with it?
No, no, no. Wait. Hurts. Stop this fight.
Don't talk over and please I'm looking
at it so it'll just, it's time.
Cause they were showing up.
I want to, I have a question.
Why is he stopping him when he's
hitting the body? Cause he was,
because he has nothing. He saw the
response when he touched the liver.
You see his body just kind of
shut down right there and her may,
he's a human being.
So He's feeling questioning his decision
earlier anyway and if he sees the
chance he's going to take it.
Yeah,
he knew it was a bad place
for cowboy right there.
He was getting lit up
and it's easier to say,
and you can be a couch quarterback
here. I think it's, he say, man,
Donald shouldn't have fought this soon,
but honestly,
the Yoshi should not allow Donald to fight
six weeks after suffering brain Trump.
No commission should have cleared them.
His coaches shouldn't allow. He wants to,
and that's the cowboy way.
Cowboy losing number 12 guy in the world.
How we can be world fucking champion.
Right?
But you gotta you gotta he's a
thoroughbred man. Treat them like that.
Don't let them do this wild shit.
It's a different game.
Doing something that you would never
see a guy like Floyd Mayweather do,
for example, or Connor or Connor
would never do that. Yeah.
Fighting six weeks after a
war. It's his life. I get that.
But also he's not making CanNor money.
He's not making Floyd money either.
You know what I'm saying? He can do that
if he was world champion, right? Yeah.
That's the argument. Right? He
needs to be protected from himself.
He's too tough for his own good.
That's the case with a lot of warrior.
I support these guys a choice to do
what they want to do. I was like,
if a doctor says you can't fight,
then you don't fight a,
if your family talks to you and gives
you advice and you'll want to take it,
you don't have to take it.
You get to a free society we live in.
You can eat as much sugar
and fat as you want to eat.
You can smoke as many
cigarettes as you want to smoke.
You can do as much heroin and cocaine
until you at least until you have brain
damage or you have brain trauma which
can cause you to be impulsive and make
decisions that maybe you're not as part
of the game. That's what you signed up.
What I'm saying is your team should
try to protect you from yourself.
They would have stopped that fight of
Greg Jackson would have stopped it.
Right there would have been,
you're talking to a former fighter,
Donald that could have like fucked the
relationship. I don't know. Maybe Donald,
maybe Donald would have said,
why the fuck did you stop that guy
in my bed all night, all weekend?
You never know. You never know.
Stool. I think he was out on a stool.
He looked like he was delirious.
I think he got hit.
If we go back to that first round at the
end of that first round and he got hit
fucking hard man.
He's a sit down down go,
what do you want to do?
What do you want to do?
Do you want to be known as the cowboy and
you were in a bar 20 years from now or
like that guy fought everyone all
the time. That was awesome man.
Or do you want to be known as a world
fucking champions stopped doing this.
Hold on. You already said this but Eddie,
I think that what you're saying is true,
but I think what you're saying is
true to what you're saying is true.
His guys have come back from that,
but what he's saying is guys
don't come back from that.
If they take the kind of beating that
they took just six weeks ago and it's
something that goes against kind of what
Donald's been saying because Donald's
been saying that he doesn't
spar anymore and his camps.
One of the reasons why
it isn't spar anymore.
It's because he took too
much fucking punishment.
He'd go into these fights
already damaged Donald.
He does drills now cause there's almost
primarily drills and when he spars,
he does it all. They do it like Thai
style. They're just touching each other.
So he's working on his timing.
He knows how to fight already here.
He knows he's tough.
There's no questions.
So it's all just about getting your
timing and your endurance down.
So I think you're right. Like guys have
come back from getting hit like that.
Like Frankie Edgar against gray, her
came back to stopping a lot. Yeah,
it's happening as much time.
But you're right. You're right.
But I think he's right too because I
think that that fight from six weeks ago
that's, that was a war. It really
was. He was in a war with a killer.
People forget that.
We know because we see the highlight
him murking Matt Brown with a head kick
that's like before. How's it took a little
shy. He got dropped. He did get dropped.
That's right. Good point. In
the end, whether you're his
coach or his best friend,
you're his family member. You say what
you feel and then he's going to decide.
See, I don't, I don't agree with that.
Well, let's talk. His coaches should go.
We listen.
We know you want to fight til the death,
but the logical thing is don't fight
in Denver against the number 15 guy.
Let's wait. Let's fight the number
four guy and then you get a title shot.
Let's do that. I agree with you. That
would be the most intelligent thing to do,
but it's a big fight coming up in Denver.
If cowboy did get a fight
against a guy who could,
when he could beat and he
did win in Denver, he would
have been a hero, right? Oh,
he's already a hero. I honestly think
that he wanted to feel the goal.
He wanted to feel it again
at one 70 it's different.
He's fighting number 14 one 70 cause
he's new to one strike number five.
It's crazy. [inaudible] 70 in the world.
He's pretty close to a title shot.
I will say this though,
the upside to being a UFC champion or a
fight or the upside is the most amazing
feeling of getting your hands right,
knocking someone out in the octagon,
payscale to know that it's, it's the,
it's the upside that it's the greatest.
I'm sure I've never fought, but I'm sure
when those guys, when Chuck Liddell wins,
it's like you're the king of the
world in the UFC championship.
That's the upside. You, you're
going to have a feeling that no,
very few people taste.
It's like ultimately quick Chuck Odell
throw his arms back. The ultimate look.
The downside is there. Yeah,
man, there's a lot of risky shit.
That's why the sport is so big because
it's so much risk for it will never grow.
Everyone thinks that way.
We're going to be the sport to grow.
It doesn't need it because guys
like Conor McGregor who's going,
I'm not taking that fight. You know
what? I'm not doing that. You know what?
I'm going to wait and do this.
They got big with doing the UFC program
and now he's beyond that and he's gone
beyond that. But he's grown the sport.
I think at this point, you know,
in the beginning of the UFC we
always had, uh, um, you know,
be careful how you, uh, explain the
fights and the rules and, and, and,
and how everything was broken down. But
now it doesn't matter. The UFC so big,
we don't have to like, oh look, we want
the sport to be huge. It's already huge.
Right? It's on another
level though. Crazy level,
man that's on Fox. I mean, it's
crazy. I kind of agree with Howard.
The Conor McGregor is taking it to the
next level and it's going to go one level
above that.
I think it's going to continue to grow
and it's not by taking stupid fights and
just never become Wilson
about being professional.
And I think if you did look at it in a
professional manner, I agree with Brendan,
but I also agree with Eddie. We're both
right, Brendan. Yeah, well there's no,
there's no difference on your fighter
because here's the thing, he kind of,
Gregor took the fight with Nate Diaz
on very fucking short notice. 11 days.
It takes 11 days notice,
five fights at 70 you know,
it doesn't cut any weight at all when
he's supposed to be fighting in 55 for the
title takes a giant chance
and winds up losing. Okay,
so you're right and you're wrong.
Like that's part of what made the legend
of Conor McGregor that he's willing to
do something so fucking crazy.
But now he,
now he's in this stratospheric position
worries world while we're dads come up
to me and my fucking kids school and
they want to talk to me about that crazy
Irish guy, Tim. Yeah. Yeah.
They don't, they don't,
no one wants to talk to anyone anymore.
They don't know who the fuck
Francis and Gando is. They will,
they will guarantee you Francis year,
fuck yeah, I bought that tonight.
The heavyweights are always the scariest.
You know that that kind
of scare market people.
He keeps marketing people like that
emerge people get the personality.
Then he got some, he said
Tyson, he's got character.
Never been allowed to come out to Chicago.
Then yes,
I can name a few. I don't want to, I
want to see him screaming in French.
Stopped getting them to talk in English.
I want you to
grab his cock and like bring it out,
scream and throw it in the camera.
That is a super athlete.
There was a rare,
rare athlete with some serious
fucking ability and end mindset.
He's got a destroyers mindset that guys
all the tools to be a world champion,
but Kenny get by a guy like Cain
saw was the right way.
Keynes going to try to impress you.
It's at least it used always female double
jab overhead. Right?
Still it's the right idea.
You know he's coming towards you instead
of straight back and roll the shoulder
out on an angle.
You still need to catch him coming in
the concept.
You go back to Canaan fought Nogueira.
There was no one like him at all
for just feeling his body just can't
fuck. Are we talking about? Yeah, he
beat the fucking broke twice. Twice.
Jd has never been the same.
Never been the same.
I've been saying well the amount of
damage they took in those fights was
catastrophic and you, you just, he
had a pace that no one can fuck with.
You couldn't keep up with it.
He just would keep it on you
over and over and over again,
but his body just does not seem like
it can handle that kind of that kind of
that a lot of fights though,
like even if it were to stop right now
to me still the greatest UFC heavyweight
of all.
Yes,
I agree but I feel like he could have
been the greatest greatest of all time.
One is right up there with him,
his Fay door and you've got to give the
nod to fade or based on most recent for
like his own canes,
most recent fights you look at like
[inaudible] and you're like, man,
you got to kind of,
it's taught when you look at it on paper
like fade or during his hay day was
something special for doom, beat fade or
though and that was like a legit fence.
Not really the first guy
to do his own coaches.
We're already talking about his lack of
preparation after the Brett Rogers fight.
They said that he put a say in that,
but we really didn't see no at Rogers
in his own coach was saying that he went
up and he uses old tricks but he didn't
prepare correctly. Is Brett Rogers?
Nolan did. Yeah, but Dallas
now fucking agent try.
Fuck Dude.
Brett.
Brett Rogers got arrested is trying to
fuck dude and he's homeless and then went
to prison doing the same shit.
So he got arrested after kind of touch
and two guys and then they sent him to
prison and then in jail he was
accused of touching his ma.
She knocks him out and then fucks him.
I don't know him being your
fucking cell man. God Damn it.
Good time. He's the biggest
guy I've ever seen in my life.
I remember interviewing him with,
and I'm not a tall man,
but holding my hand straight up in the
air to interview him when famous show
haymaker.
Right.
Have you ever see the animated Gif
where his head goes flying off?
It has his head goes flying off and it's
slams against the camera and creates
this big bladder. Him The
internet is amazing. Fucking Huh?
What'd you guys think of the Tito chail
fight? It was a legit fight for sure.
Anybody is saying that it was a
work they looking at slow motion.
They're saying that like Tito,
like motion thing.
If you speed it up to like real time
and then the fight was going on,
it's like this. He's trying to
hand fight. Yeah, he's trying to,
he's trying to figure out what to do,
whether it could tuck his chin,
whether he could move.
And by the way,
you got to recognize that Tito has
had serious fucking neck surgery.
He's got fused disks in his neck,
so he gets out of sketchy.
If someone's grabbing his neck,
understand why, but it just, you know,
it was a bigger, stronger guy who
got ahold. There's the look of that.
Oh,
the
washes get it comes out.
Yeah.
He's the craziest animated Gif file.
So sick.
Right hand of all time.
The timing, man. Dude,
the fucking Internet is amazing.
Actually.
Look at the way you could probably
do that back and calf foot comes off.
See the ways back foot.
It's actually a pitch.
Mcgregor's left hand when it's done
right is the same thing. It's not,
it's not a turning punchy
pivot and just wings.
We rose countdown videos was like Kim in
the mountains like with fucking big logs
and shit.
You remember when he,
when he fought 'em what
the fuck's his name? Tim.
Sylvia. When you'd fucked
up to him. Jesus Christ.
Oh my God. It's Tim Silvia. Silvia
was Tim Sylvia. That was me.
Still fucking beat the wild wild west
where everyone's doing everything.
Tim Silvia's basically seven foot with
a great jab and great deck gun offense.
People forget about Tim Silvia. They
paid him six or $700,000 for that minute.
Tim Silvia. Good. Yeah, it's
good pain. Clobber knackered.
But I think that like if you
go back to the Tim Silvia,
that Fault Rigo Rodriguez, Oh my
God, it's my favorite. Tim Silvia.
Tim still jacked all the steroids
had
giant killer CV.
Can find that Jamie,
pull up Tim Silvia versus
Rico Rodriguez. And, uh, Tim,
if you listen to me right now and
you're mad at me now, I'm a fan.
But you know you were on the shit so
shut the fuck up. I know. I love you.
I think he had been at it.
We're not breaking any news here.
It's funny. He was so scary
though when he was juiced up.
He was so scared guy when
he was watching stuff days.
Those are the days of a different,
it was a different world.
The juice to it when he fought Nogueira.
I don't think so.
I think that we should watch that. I've
been testing the testing got significant.
Yeah. Little Lucy, not me. Not like now.
Now you take a fucking caffeine,
cast you back.
Then after the fight they had a few
randoms. They did occasionally back then.
Like dude's got like Ausra
got busted. Remember? Yeah.
Officer got busted on a random
dude's got busted on randoms.
Very recommissioned with the
commission would test you. Yeah.
Well they started ramping it up right
around the time that they decided that
this testosterone replacement therapy,
those arms, dude, he was so jacked.
See if you can find the video. Jamie
was a fuck. Even his face, his muscular.
Great. Back then. Holy Shit. Oh my
God. It was jack. He still was jack.
He was heavy duty steroids because they
teased him about his body at the gym.
Yeah.
He said he wanted a six pack.
He kept saying he was going to have a
six pack. Kept telling me, I go, dude,
you don't need a six pack.
You're smashing. People
don't. Facts are for everyone.
You didn't need it.
He was,
but he was jack back down like
he didn't have a bad boss.
He did everything to get the fans
that love. Remember he came out to,
I forget what he
come out. He came out to all of the G. No,
he came out to g walks and
then you turn the Mike Mike.
There'd be booing me like I'm doing it
for the troops like doing and it came out
of the American flag. He
did. You check it off.
People are going to love this and they
still just didn't wear the Jersey and
everything, but we can't
beg for it. You can't bet.
How did he look like a big bully I guess?
Hmm. Tim Silvia is entrance to
Sylvia versus Vera Brandon Vera.
That was back when Brandon vera was it
Marion Brown and on the mic after knocking
out Frank Mir was like and be light
heavyweight champion heavyweight
champ pioneered that.
Conor McGregor and then they
signed a shit load. We got paid
well it took a long time before he got
paid. They was out for a long time.
But here's the other thing that happened.
He stopped training with rob came in.
That was a big factor in his early success
is that he was training with one of
the greatest kickboxers of all time.
And Rob came in is so technical.
I trained with rob for quite a bit
when I was supposed to do that.
Wesley snipes things I did all my
striking with Rob Cayman and dude I was,
I had an understanding of like how people
set things up and systems and systems
that they struck under him.
But I had no idea that there was someone
out there that have that kind of depth
to their thought process behind striking
cause all we would do four days a week
was get together and talk strategy and
technique and striking and he would
explain things to me and then we would
hit pads and then after we hit pads,
like two days a week I'd
spar with somebody mantle
and dude rob came in is a bad
motherfucker man.
His techniques and his is
like his strategy and mean
that way he breaks things
down. Mastermind. Oh he's,
he's genius man. And it's,
it makes you really truly appreciate
like when you would watch his fights now
you'll see like all the
shit that he's setting up.
We don't have to hold on on the
table anymore. It's legal now.
That must've been awesome Joe.
Being able to do that with,
with rob came in and tell
Joe who you want to do that.
That's smart too. Yeah. I asked Matt, he's
a bad mother. He's a bad motherfucker.
He's,
I think he's the best coach in the game.
He has the best fighter in the game
and I think he's got the big picture.
He puts the whole thing together.
He is the strength and conditioning coach.
He's the everything coach.
And because of that he can periodize
everything properly. So you know,
you're not sending your
guy over to another guy,
unsure of when he's tired of what
he's doing on his schedule. He's,
he schedules it all and Demetrius
actually trains a little bit less than
everybody else
rests more. That's very smart. Well,
the thing about a guy like Matt humans,
he's also got physical capabilities
that mirror worldclass fighters.
Like he can fight like really fighting.
You Watch his fight with Pat
Miletich way back in the day.
He fucked up pat military. She was like
one of the first super high level guys,
like super early on. Hey
Brian, you and the bathroom,
are you in the kitchen rather buddy?
Can you get me one of them?
Cam butches one of them.
Um,
well in Cam,
Gucci Calm Booch can Bluetooth.
I'll go with
one of those jammy.
Um, yeah, he's
um, he's a wizard man and
he's seen it all. You know,
he was a judge back in
the glory days of pride.
He never fought in the UFC,
but easily could. Thank you
sir. Easily, easily caught.
Yeah. I caught some of his fights
ever and pancreas and stuff.
I've broken him down from all fights and
it was one of them where he was riding
this guy's hip and just spent
the whole fight back here.
And at the time it was just so out of
character and I broke it down and then I,
I saw him and he's like, yeah, thanks
for doing that. That was really nice.
I'm like, cool. I said, how'd you do that?
And he just matter of factly. It's like,
well, I knew he didn't understand this
particular kind of freestyle wrestling.
So I just designed the entire thing about
doing something he didn't understand,
which was so natural to him.
Also,
his dad trained with Bruce Lee
or, or um, uh, Dan Inosanto.
So Bruce Lee to Dan
Inosanto to Matt's Dad.
Like the lineage is still super legit,
so smart.
So I asked him if I could come and just
stay in a cheap hotel nearby and come to
shadow him for 10 or 12 days on my
own for my own costs for vacation.
I said I cleaned the gym and whatever
I could do to help, and he said, yeah,
I'm not opposed to it. Just circle back
to him. He's gonna make you clean the gym.
I offer it. I shouldn't offer the
abroad. I'm going to start slow.
Give me a couple of bucks. Oh, you don't
need to. I'll thanks man. Well done.
Let me give you
a hundred y'all go social media on you.
I'll put some Instagram posts.
I'll do a breakdown every fucking
day of all the stuff. Videotape him.
I want to do a piece on you.
Yeah.
I told them I would document
it if he didn't mind, but
I didn't. Don't need that.
I want you to new inspiration
said maybe February, maybe march,
some mighty mouse is in camp.
Yep. How often do you train in?
Three times a week if you're
doing them a matron, Jujitsu,
powerlifting and strength and conditioning
and strength and conditioning.
I'm always trying to customize it with
my coach Paul to Mimic what I'm seeing
guys too.
So you know,
everybody was moving so I had to start
to understand agility and direction
change and stuff like that.
So customized,
strengthen conditioning for things that
I'm trying to understand concepts and
I'll do Jiu Jitsu once a week. I've
got a kickboxing coach, Evan Boris,
who is one of Henry's guys, Henry
hoofs guys, he's up in Toronto,
he's really good and he's a good
friend so we can talk to go.
He left in Florida,
I don't know where he's going to
do and a lot of those athletes,
which just went with them right
away. He's the jam of that. He's,
he's as good as it gets
man. And you know, so it's,
it's weird political shit
when you put really smart,
talented people all together.
If they don't have the exact same vision,
some weird shit to chemistry thing,
you can't just throw it.
It's like the pro bowl. He can't
just hope all these guys get along.
There's too many egos.
Winkeljohn is so unusual.
Those guys like Gel together so well k
eightK is a good example to Mike Brown is
so cool man. I kind of know one of
the most humble guys in the game.
He's like more celebrate talk that if
you run a gym together like you gotta
like, like Eddie, you
and I could run a gym
together cause we know each other so well.
We're,
we've been such good friends for so long.
We could run a gym together easy.
You and I would have no problem.
We might disagree about some shit,
but we disagree about shit all the time.
We never have a problem.
You see one way I see another way.
But we would talk about things.
We could actually run a gym and I would,
I don't think,
I couldn't imagine we would have
a problem at all. I couldn't,
I couldn't foresee anything that we
couldn't work out. Let's do an MMA show,
the soccer field.
I'm fucking
Hallock and that other guy
find on big soccer. Like
I liked that fight, man. I don't give a
fuck what anybody says and props down.
No problem. Perhaps to how it, Gracie,
I love the fact that you didn't just
take a fight after a long time off.
You took a fight to pay your debts.
You took a chance with Metamorris I,
it's a big thing to take a chance.
All the criticisms aside,
which I'm sure he would agree,
many of them are valid.
That fucking guy took a fight.
You'll pay his debts and he took a chance
to start metamorris in the first place.
It's not an easy thing to do, but to
give Jujitsu, professional Jujitsu,
a platform and a high profile platform
and get guys like Eddie to fight guys
like boiler, get all the guys and he
got to fight. He put on some very,
very good shows. Josh Barnett,
he had some really good level,
high level guys and I think
it elevated the profile,
Jujitsu and then to go in there with that.
How do you say his name?
Sasaki cocktail. Cocteau.
It's [inaudible].
That guy is a bad motherfucker. He
said dangerous, legitimate striker.
He's knocked out Joe Schilling twice.
Not only just selling an item,
he doesn't get hurt. He
doesn't get hurt. He goes,
three fucking room gets touchy as
amazing. Tim. He mounts in him.
He's dominating him in the
last minute of the last round.
I don't give a fuck what anybody says.
That's what I like about Jujitsu.
That's what I like about martial arts.
When I see a fight like that, I like it.
That fight was fucking terrible for me.
I'm glad you guys,
I think I don't have that on a football
field though. Yeah. Yeah. We've got,
again, it would be, there
would be no fight. Where was,
where'd the fight take place or where did
the fight go to the ground? Like wait,
did they clot? No, but they collide
with the cage at all. I don't remember.
I don't remember.
I don't remember exactly when it was
against the kids only take that cage away.
Action. It's a lot tougher for
Haluk window catch. Lots of,
for everybody's tougher for
Cocteau to hit him to run. Yeah.
You could move away and get zero action.
That's okay.
That was always an never in
a cage to a combat sambo is.
Oh. So it's proven that it actually does
work and there's no obstruction when
there's not a wall or a cage way better.
There's no reason to go to the outside.
But to this premium room,
it doesn't have to be a football feed,
like a basketball court is plenty of
fucking room. I like what happened that,
so the marsh, the combat will evolve
around the playing surface, the rules,
the everything. And having that cage
made some beautiful martial arts though.
Like the, all the combat against the cage,
just beautiful. It is. But in a better,
when there's no other thing there,
there's no other factor is just
two fighters with their bodies to
Splore. Yeah, you could eliminate,
but it's a sport. When there's no cage,
you get a lawyer of they fight factor.
But you can live in a fact.
It's still not just to fight
cause there's no headbutts. No,
I gouges know a lot of strikes, know,
shot feedback of the head. No talking,
no cage. Unified rules
of MMA. I do. It would be
this morning.
So Nikki,
I liked the way it is. I love the way
it is. There's nothing wrong with it.
Who loves the way it is more than I do.
I love it. I do on the football field,
I wanted an a a basketball court.
See, we're making improvement.
Went from football to basketball.
Sleep better on a basketball court.
The audience would have,
they would have to look at the,
at the screen the whole time. The
audience here, if you're on the floor,
you think you got the good seats on
the door. You got terrible seats.
If you're on the 200 people on the floor,
the good, the good seats are the risers
on the floor. No Shit.
But here's the thing.
In a basketball court, there's no floor.
So all that shit you see, that's floor.
That would all be risers. Risers. Oh,
do it would be perfect.
Perfect. It'd be great. Let's
do it. We can't get something.
I'll talk to start it up.
Set it up.
Eddie and I are going to form an
organization going to make everyone aware.
Rash guards to mandatory.
Love it. No, no, no.
Greeson eliminates the greasing
tap planet. MMA. People
are greasing all the time.
There's nobody checking. It's
illegal, but there are no test for it.
Plus it's a big problem.
That dude's agree. Anytime.
Some guy who fights at black belt in
Jujitsu, of course he's going to Greece,
he's going to do it. No one
backing that. Just oil in the bath.
But you guys know tag check.
There's no, no one's getting busted.
Like they're not swabbing
their backs. There's Vaseline
all over your face, right?
You know, uh, uh,
sports always change rules and
add things to increase the office.
They never do.
They never change shit to increase the
defense for the entertainment value is,
and you need fail. Does
it? NBA does it. They are.
They're trying to increase the
offense. Baseball, they do it.
They're doing a shot clock and more
offense in fighting is more knockouts and
more submissions. More the more
submissions of org awesome submissions.
People love them.
The better for the sport when God guides
of greasing up and there's no tests and
the easy way to fix that, have them wear
rash guards, have them aware of what,
what, uh, Juliana Penny's wearing.
No big deal. It's not a problem
where her rash guards all the time, you
get out their titties out exactly exact,
but that the kids have arms.
Could they or should they be able to
cover their arms and legs? Aoki. Tights,
tights. That's an advantage though.
What an advantage is more offense, dude.
That's what we're talking about.
Tweaking shit from where we go.
Round one shift Chanko or precinct
four 50 44534502451 the more grease,
the less submissions. It's a, this
is a really interesting fight here.
Chef Chanko is one of the best fucking
strikers in MMA, period. Any man, woman,
whatever.
She super solid and that check right hook
that she kept nailing Holly Holm with
excellent, excellent footwork.
Superstrong Moy, Tai wants to,
she's more decorated than Yolanda
and Holly. Johann kickbox.
Yeah, she beat you on a,
she's a lot bigger. So,
and now she's about to have her way out
of here. She's going across the face now.
She's way more bulked up now than then.
I believe they were the same
weight when they, fuck. Wow.
She's making good choices
here against the fence.
[inaudible] agrees that she's got to
take her down, right? Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
You gotta take shift Chanko
what if, what if she can't?
She's got to get knocked down.
Knocked over. Next we're going to see,
we're going to see, because this is her
whole strategy. Giuliana is tough as fuck.
She's very strong but she's
not a striker like in the,
in the realm of Chep Cenk skilled
discrepancies. Massive. Massive.
She's going to be defensive to close
the distance and then this is what she's
going to concentrate on the body
part. All part. That's awesome.
She got taken out. I take downs and that
was a great choice to go black belt.
She's going to let that happen.
Why would she stop that judo black belt
could have been just a ploy to get the
fight to the ground. Cause cause a
lot of people are saying opinion.
The clinch is going to whoop her ass.
I'm like,
she's a judo black belt are inside
trips and our hips are ridiculous.
So another reason to pull
guard. Yup. Yeah, for sure.
She's also super physically strong.
She had pain.
Who's doing all the right
stuff to chest fully like,
but that's also the thing man pen.
His whole deal is on the ground being
on the ground and on the ground.
She's super solid.
But when you're dealing with a woman
who's a judo black belt and a nasty
kickboxer boy you got a weird room to move
in. You got a tough fucking fire dude.
It seems like the smart thing to
do is don't waste all your energy.
Just pull garden. That's a great idea.
But he's smart thing to do too though.
She's butt blasting or with
knees to the body. I mean bad.
If she could pull it off,
you won't forget chef Genco.
A lot of people think the Amanda
Nunez fight. It was only three rounds.
Who is five shift Chanko
probably wins that fight. Hey,
here's a pervert question.
Has any girl ever gone down
from a shot to the Twat? Girl
will they show the replay is what
you do to get kicked in the balls?
They show it in slow motion.
Took it down again.
She's got that great timing on
the trip that Judah look at us.
Cause the legs, the feet aren't even
on the ground. Take down. Yeah. No,
she just gets tripped. She's throwing
knees and she's getting tripped
and wants it on the ground and shift.
Chanko hasn't been regarded once or even
close to it. She's just crowding or,
yeah,
she'll smarter shift Janka yeah.
Juliana could recover a half guard and
if she's got half guard game or butterfly
game or full guard came home
and just got to recover.
She's trying to get to slide and get some
kind of guard Shannon across cause she
could just stand up and back out.
She's got to hold onto shift Chanko
so he's got to hold onto don't fucking
strong man.
She's like a coil,
like a steel coil and now she's got,
she's got her in three quarter garden now,
so she's good to strike the breasts.
I mean it should be,
you can't strike a woman's not wearing
genital protection at all. Right? Yeah.
They haven't got a cup.
No.
What kind of chastity belt do that
and they brought a cop, right?
I don't think so. But you're saying right
or do you know pretty sure they do. Jen,
I don't know. Jamie, can
you please look that up?
I wouldn't look like they're wearing a
cup will protect. That's what I'm saying.
Like if you got hit with
the need of the clearest,
I'm sorry for calling a Twat earlier lady.
So it's just doing it for comedic effect.
Um,
but if if you do get hit in your
vagina with a knee strike or a kick,
I've got to think that's
going to be very painful.
We haven't done is like we're a girl
just buckled and level like some dudes do
know like when Vandelay got kicked by
Gilbert Ivl stop the fight kicked him
right in the nut. Got,
can you punch the titties?
Like could you just start elbow
into the tit? I don't think you can.
I think the breasts are off limit. You
can. Has anyone done on those rules?
Caldor that Joe,
I heard you say before that if a grind
shots were legal guys wouldn't be going
down like this and I agree with you 100%.
You would become a climatized to it.
There's an entire martial arts
developed so that you don't take
oh shot here.
Even if she pulls out,
she has a chance. That's where
chances, it's just style.
Dance. She could swim and take her to
spiderweb right here. Put that Shim.
She's never putting the shit the,
oh,
he's got to get that deep hooker
left hook isn't deep enough.
She's got to lose it.
What the [inaudible] she got taken down
and Landon I can show and that was still
good for all she had to do was recover
piece by piece, inch by inch. Look,
she ended almost an arm bar. That's where
she has, she needs to keep doing that.
Get, she's not resisting the
takedown. She's letting her take him.
Maybe she wants to find on the ground.
She's losing that.
Ram had a chance.
She would have definitely lost if she
would have just stayed in standards.
Do it with her. But here's my
question. When men, uh, fight,
they don't have them where any
specific type of cup, right.
They don't tell them you have to
work in shorts checked at the front.
You have to at least show your
way regular. Those are bullshit.
Those are stupid. Okay.
It says, what does it say?
Jail female and him wearing.
Wow.
I did not know that.
Female mixed martial artists wear a
chest protector. That's some bullshit.
Where a chest protector shall,
thou shall wear a chest protector during
competition. Do they mean those, those
sports bra chest protector shall be
subject to approval by the commission.
So what kind of alerts or they can
have a hard one. Is that what it is?
Like we're going to chest
protector these girls.
Why do you just mean you got to
cover, what state is this, Jamie?
That's the UFC. UFC. Mm.
So they're wearing so much to have some
padding on your nipples or something.
Hold on. She's trying to hope for it to
go for that arm swing like a knee pad.
But look how rugged chef co is.
A brute dragger last attempt to that.
Her core is so God damn strong.
I mean she tried so hard to drag
her down to the ground like that,
but her's cores so strong
or takedowns are so strong.
It's one of the things I saw
her first UFC bound. I was like,
this girl is not just a kickboxer man.
She's so physically strong.
When you were talking about movement,
whether you train with a movement coach
and you trained with a different kind of
strength and conditioning or something,
when you can connect the upper and lower
through the core so powerfully and have
all the, you know, your nervous system,
be able to move everything together that
way it just makes you better guaranteed
balance. Man. No one's got
balanced like judo players.
They're so good at shift in their
hips and and adjusting their balance.
Those guys are so hard to take down
the lifetime of that and girls rather
obviously,
but you know what?
You get that from breakdancers get
definitely gymnast even get that from like
taekwondo people. Like a lot of people
that are used to doing things on one leg,
like throwing kicks and stuff on one leg.
A lot of times those guys can adjust
really well and take down attempts and
movement. Look at Man, do you guys find
that taekwondo people play a better guard?
They just have better sophistication with
their feet and the legs more. No Room.
So no, no. The guard play start out with
the card players have a different kind of
flexibility first of all because the most
important flexibility isn't like full
splits. The most important
flexibility is growing flexibility.
It's like knee to chest, foot to face, the
ability to go double lotus to put your,
your legs behind your head.
That's so much more critical than
what's what you use in taekwondo.
So the dexterity is different.
I definitely think strong
legs plays a big factor.
Like if you,
if you're grappling with anybody who's
got strong legs for any reason and then
they developed a dexterity and figure out
how to use them well extra slags. Yeah,
I mean your legs carry your
whole body around all day, man.
You know the difference between he's a
grinder and break dancers is the gymnast
or doing set routines and
breakdancers improvise.
So judge and that's why it's better
for Jujitsu. I may size do come in,
Jim has do come in and they got that,
you know,
crazy monkey body strength.
But Jujitsu is about making lightening
quick decisions and so quick that you
can't actually make them yourself.
You have to feel the body adapts body
as your body is going to make the
decisions based on how it was trained.
That's it. If you're thinking about it,
you're just,
but Juliana,
she does not give her up. That was
beautiful, but she crushes are away
from the octagon to she's fucking tough
as shit. Shit. She described herself,
she said on the hardest woman in the
MMA, the, you know when you said the MMA,
I fucked it up. When you are one
round Gail piece, after this one,
when you're out scale, then you're winning
with heart at. That's what we said.
Going into this one,
you got something.
You're fighting somebody way more skilled
and experienced than you in a lot of
areas, but you have more heart and that's
impressive when you can make that work.
That's all. I don't know it.
I'm telling you man should Chanko has
some nasty Jujitsu playing chess Giuliana
chef submission. She
does. She does. She does.
She played the whole risk of
going old school, pickles,
attention those guard man.
She puts her head strong ass legs to
those kickboxing legs, those legs,
or they got some fucking horsepower
behind a man who's expanding the work.
I mean here. Who's spending
both of them? Both of them are.
Both of them are shift
Shankles. No joke man. No,
but she's got a dish that ankle tattoo
too late.
She's gone for seven 1980s nineties I
mean, I don't think she has the setups.
Tap, tap painter based on what I see
right here. Her Garden, she hurts her.
She has she, she gets posture. She lets
it go. She gets it. She lets it go.
That tells me that posture is not
that important to her and that's not,
there's no way you could
have a high level garden. Oh
my God. Oh, that's good though.
Oh,
I have to break your shit off
to Eddie, but I was like,
this is going to be hilarious.
What does that call when
that happens? Wow. Ironic.
How do you say that?
You could ever be,
but I just don't know.
So far just it seemed like she
wasn't really attacking. That's,
that's what I based it on.
But she just went for it.
She just swung her hips and
just fucking went for pain.
You got a little cocky in there, you know?
And she, she beats, she beats in India.
I think she wanted me to throw rounds.
So what happened in the first fight
at noon as one at close to Susan Shift
Chenko adapted and by round three
she was in better shape by round.
She just snapped up here. Oh, you
know about Nunez, man. She's just,
she's a nasty,
vicious striker,
but you are just not going to be able
to tee off like that on shift Genco.
She's not going to be five rounds.
She's not going to be there.
She's not going to be there. She's going
to be standing southpaw. First of all,
she's going to be sliding off to the
right. She's always going to threat.
Slash she's gotta throw nasty leg pants.
Chew your legs up.
But you know, we know what one,
ah, I used to commentate for pride.
Let's write 10 Hanzo fought Sakharova.
I'm commentating,
I'm the color guy and soccer.
Robert has a Kamora grip
on Hanzo and out. And my commentary
was, well that's not gonna work.
I mean it may be worth [inaudible] is Jim,
but
he gets it embraces art.
It's a real story.
It was worse than that because I was
actually commentating the show telling you
you might be looking at the best women's
MMA fighter in the world, right? Yeah.
[inaudible] Nunez has a mullet.
Yup. Her cause her head,
her cause her hand celebrate that
tonight. It's her calls her, hey,
any champion a mullet. But
when you think about it, okay,
you are one of the fucking world experts
in something and even you can be fooled
by watching that.
So when people are saying they know
what's going to happen or could make it
picks, even the highest level of
expertise in the world can be deceived by,
by what you see. If that's a compliment,
that's a compliment because it is.
You were right up until that moment and
then you saw something that made you
give her a bit a different
perspective of it.
This is what I've been trying to
tell people about all martial arts.
Like when you were looking at fade or
whether we're looking at cane in the
moment, you can have an
idea of how good someone is.
You couldn't have an idea of what's going
to happen if their fight somebody else,
but really you never know and really
you never know how good they're going to
like how good it's going to look
until the whole thing's gone down.
Perfect examples, Ronda Rousey, like
if you look at Ronda Rousey, Rhonda,
when she was dominating women was
dominating women that, let's be honest,
at that stage of women's MMA, it
was flourishing. It was growing,
but you had Gina Carano versus Cyborg
and that was the highest expression of
women's MMA before the UFC.
So you have strike force,
strike force has some very good fights.
Rhonda shines,
Meesha shines and then boom during
the UFC and the women are sort of not,
you know, you get Betcha.
[inaudible] you've got Alexis
Davis, you're not getting,
you're not getting this.
This is some next level shit
and this is what happens, man.
Just like MMA from 97 2017 has exploded
and become a totally different thing.
This is the same way.
Same with the women,
but that doesn't mean that Matt Matt
Hughes isn't one of the greatest fucking
welterweight of all time.
Even though Matt Hughes may be,
doesn't stack up with today.
You got a little time to time.
He's an iPhone one and he's got
an iPhone and that one was sick.
Exactly.
The fucking suck.
And the mass phone call Zack change and
people change and they change moment to
moment to, and the truth,
the word truth. You know,
we describe things with opinions and
using limited language and all of these
things, but the truth is
the moment, the truth,
you know of all the
cliches in fucking sports,
the moment of truth is
the fucking best one too.
You go into a fight and they say,
go, that is the moment of truth.
It's fucking truth. Rise. Do cyborg
versus Rhonda.
No can,
I don't know Ron tracks over do that.
First of all,
I think contractually she could fight
outside the UFC and I don't think she
would fight outside the
UFC and I definitely don't
think she'd fight unhealthy
that he's trying to see people's shit.
She retired.
You want to see people does the contract
once you retire, right? No, I've retired.
I'm retired in soon as I went, I want to
fight someone else. Do you have c goes,
cool. Here's your contract.
They freeze it. Yep. Oh yeah,
like Walt Disney. The, yes,
that's true. Yup. Yeah.
It's not that simple and I don't think
she would do that anyway. No, nothing.
I'm most likely terrible idea. Why
not? Cause I think first of all,
Cyborg is probably walking around
north of one 99 I'm not exaggerating.
She was doing dead lifts with three.
She's mad at me by the way.
Who blocked me on Twitter? Cyborg.
Cyborg. If you listen, I'm not,
I'm not a hater. I'm not a hater, but
I have to call him like I see him,
good or bad.
I tweeted a long time ago that I'd like
to see the UFC open on one hour and 45
pound division. So cyborg could fight the
people that are her way. Welcome Cyborg.
But I was saying that a long time ago
because this is even before all the
controversy where me and Tony got in
trouble for joking around about her.
But this was, I was saying like,
it's crazy to try and make this grow.
Go to 35 she's not 35 pound fighter.
She's just struggle to get the 45 letter
fight at 45 and let's see what's up.
But build it. They will come, they will.
There will be continuing to take awhile.
But that fucking moment she would,
I stand right here in the middle some
she got upset because they're saying no,
you guys going to fight you and I'm going
to win. And then she, I met off that.
Yeah. And one laugh that the other one,
she looks like a bad guy from commando,
but it was doing girl crazy.
That's Russian dance, Russian
twerking. There are hard people.
She's rough. She's rough.
It's a super athlete.
But let's hear what she said.
Yeah, we can back it up.
Can we give us some volume so we get
to hear that shit sac. That's bad ass.
Awesome. But anyway, about the Cyborg
thing, I got to tell the truth,
which I hear your job. Oh, I got
to tell the truth on both sides.
And she failed to use a test.
Not One but two,
you know one of them was from a different
drug and this one is for some diuretic.
That's also used as a DHT inhibitor. This
is not like this is public news. Yeah,
that's not gossip. It'd be is fair. It's
document. It is what it is. You know,
I don't,
she shouldn't have taken something that
was bad and they would never been an
issue. But let's go. Let's hear this
first. I pay money to have her attack.
Tony and Brian,
here we go.
Juliana is a resident.
Hello.
How are you willing to
deal? Is this, I love it.
She is excellent. Ooh. You show up that
discipline. You take your training camps.
Were you surprised at how successful
you were taking her down? Around one.
I was working very hard.
I was only on this fine.
Thank you to Michael.
She,
she waits for the knee.
Yeah.
Oh Shit. And she is not the
slightest. Oh yeah, I'll get that.
Nice friendly smile.
A,
it is so hilarious.
Broken English
roast battle.
It's a roast battle with broken English.
Eddie Bravo was like,
play that back.
She can dance. Oh Dude.
She's an athlete, man.
She's so goddamn pouch.
She talked to him was so bad.
That's going to be a great fight. All of
us moving ahead. We're moving forward.
We're moving forward. We're moving
forward. These are animal fighters.
That's even better.
That's even better when it happened.
You're going to get to get that
tape and you're going to chop it up.
But what she said
so important because what she said there
is that you're seeing to real world
champion caliber mixed martial artists.
They do everything Nunez.
A black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu,
choked out. Miesha Tate choked out.
Sarah McMahon. When she's a beast.
Dude, she's nasty or fucking power.
Punching saw Longreach she gets after it.
This is super dangerous.
I would fuck that cheeseburger up right
now. By the way. It looks good. Right?
Right. If only, if only it
was healthy. Mm, nice wine,
Brian. We don't pry around.
Brian knows his shit.
He knows her shit when it comes to wine.
He'll talk to Somalia about
grape locations, Darren,
right by where they grow
them on the hill vocations.
I will know whether that is a difference
between a burgundy and a Pino.
And actually it's kind of the same.
We were talking about
cannabis.
How about how
people talk about wine 50 years ago.
Way Different than they talk
about it and understand why now.
And that's the same thing
with fighting and what we see.
Those women are so much better than
women's fighting was one year ago.
Parents a one. What's interesting
subtleties and it's just,
it took a while for them to get into
the UFC and then it took a while to find
their place.
And then like when you see like someone
like you wanna like when you want to
what was super,
super evident when you wanna Fuck Carlos
bars that and when she fought Julianna
Pena when she fought, uh, not uh,
uh, Jessica went, you've got Jessica,
Jessica Peninnah. No, I always mess it up.
You fucked it up when she flat Jessica
Pinay it was a murking, you know,
it was nasty.
She was smashing her and slicing her up
with elbow is called nip tuck those job.
It was rough. It was rough. And
when you see that you're like,
okay well this didn't exist before.
When you watch those kind of
lightening fast combinations,
that front front kick to the face
she hits goes girls with I Pang,
she's digs the hips in that Nasty Long
Jab that she has just super high level
striking. And I think when you,
when you see that and you, you,
you opened the door to that,
it's like we were talking
about before about your ear,
you build it and they will come.
All these other women are going to step
in to that and they'll fill that void
was done. Rise up to
that level. He had the,
the base level rises like the bay,
Jamie chilled out TV
average level goes up.
Do you know that might still watch all,
you know the fight was the lowest
level to fight, but that's some news.
I thought it was TV. No, no, you can
still the Nogueira if want to watch that.
Hell yeah. Get that on a, is it on
fight pass? I think it's on fight pass.
See if you can find enough.
Fipass Kimbo don't
like represented, but anytime
too. I was going to say athletes,
I don't know if maybe you can put me
on this one. Came up was Ken shamrock.
That was a great fight.
Yeah.
New One 50 I mean when people
watch it and got great listening,
I couldn't wait for it to start. Did you
enjoy the fights? Couldn't wait for it.
Why don't you got to be
young to fight? Oh, what am I
senior to have? Like obstacles,
like fucking garbage cans and shit.
Things, laying around to GRANDPA's
football field. No rules.
We leave pizza boxes laying all around
the field, so do slip on them and shit.
And they fight on grass wet grass
like right after the sprinklers,
the sprinklers kick on and the crowd
roars cause that means it's all about the
[inaudible].
And then you have dudes come out and
they throw the pizza boxes down and they
have guys coming to
place the garbage cans.
Garbage cans are filled with like fucking
used cat food cans and Shit fucked up
diapers. Like yeah, cause
you got to plow into them.
It's gotta be like old dudes fighting
championships, super hot cheer.
But all those, before they
get started, they get drunk,
they do the sit there and they drink.
They seniors,
everybody like you have to have at least
four drinks before the fight starts.
They pour 'em out,
they stare at each other at the bar,
they do these shots and then the
doctor goes, okay, we're good. 75.
And they push them out there. We can
just do downtown La if you want. No,
that's crap. But it's not helping the, uh,
the thing about any of those changes you
just made, they all change everything.
Like change any one thing
and everything changes.
If we suddenly allow like kicks to the
head of a down opponent four points,
it's a whole different game.
Every position you change.
I think we were talking about it. I think
there should be no rules of any kind.
And, and I, and I got you
biting everything and,
and I don't mean you're
going to have this. Yep.
This is a parallel universe in which we
could do this. Where it isn't a sport.
Nobody will watch this. Let me, let me
get you, let me get to you right here.
What if regenerative medicine,
regenerative,
regenerative medicine reaches a point
where they can literally shoot stem cells
right into your eyeballs, grow you a
new eyeball, 100% guarantee. It's like,
it's no different than
you getting one stitch.
You get a cut that needs one stitch.
It's nothing,
but they're just going to shoot you.
You know that they do that now with
third degree burns due to have horrible
burns all over their arms.
They spray him with stem cells in your
skin grows back in like a matter of a few
days. People who were scarred for life
now have no visible scars whatsoever.
No, no, no, no, no, no. It has
to be fresh. It has to be fresh.
But while you have all that damage,
all of your body does spray stem cells
all over your body and your body just
grows tissue. It looks amazing.
Fucking amazing. Spray it.
No. Well, maybe. Maybe that might
work. Oh, it's amazing. I mean,
that's probably the future.
But once they reach that point
where a guy biting your nose off,
does it really mean you lost your notes?
Right? Then you take pictures. Hey,
I'm at the gym with a fucking look up
by nose cavity. It'd be doctor says,
no three days. Go ahead and
fire for three seconds. Yeah,
so weird check. Look up
there. Look up there.
Look at this. See, before
after fucking massive,
was that a black person before light?
After you turn white, but you're,
you're healthy.
No,
it's sprays a victim's own stem cells
onto the wounds and it regenerates tissue
at a fucking ridiculously fast rate. It
didn't say that. No, no, it does, man.
Look, you could go into it, uh, online
and see the studies that they've shown,
but it's fucking amazing.
Severe Burns and they're able
to do this procedure. Yeah.
90 minutes and within weeks there
are 100% healed. That's a ceremony.
Results within days. Look at that.
Stem cells regenerate the skin,
leaving no scars. So now do we know
this is legitimate? No, this is 100%.
100% sounds like a scam.
It's to NASA. Anytime.
Youtube and it's in the library.
The library. I just said
that. Both. Both. Yeah.
It's both Dewey decimal system.
He looked it up.
It's double pro with the last time
you went to the library. Brendan,
what does the library, he'd been
reading the librarian in Vancouver.
This way to not teach.
Canadians had to read recently
we did some research on you.
We know your background was you
were working for the other side.
So now we imagine it's okay, we can
bite. We can tear out whatever. Okay.
If that's the case and you can rebuild
tissue a hundred percent why not? So,
and the reason it would be fascinating
is because over time he'd never get,
well actually if we can rebuild it, uh
Oh my God. Every magician change the,
I suppose the face biting 20 years,
brainstorm a in the brain to your brain.
They're working on that.
They're working on regenerating traumatic
brain injuries would if it gets to the
drain kickboxing class, you know, you
can't ever spar because of brain damage.
But every night you could
go in and knock out 10 dude,
you get knocked out three times. That's
cool. It's not as cool anymore. Is it?
Because the risk is, that will always
be cool. Everyone was sitting trades.
It's like the fucking killing brain cells.
It's about shutting a
dude off and dominated.
It's about killing brain cells gives off
this shouting I'm off and dominate IOM.
No Eddie's right. If there's no
consequences physically. Yeah, yeah.
I mean then it's a totally
different thing. No one's cowboy.
That's not true. You're,
you're not, you're not,
it's not true because that's Jujitsu.
Cause you do too.
You're killing each other without
killing each other. What'd you did too?
You get a guy's back and you fucking
put that choke on him. He taps.
He's basically saying, you killed me. If
we're in the wild, we were in the jungle,
you would've killed me. So you let them
go. You slap hands. You start again.
It's better.
Like Jujitsu people I think have a better
bond than at least the gyms that I've
been around that a lot
of people that boxing,
spar and kickboxing sport because
they hurt each other. Yeah.
You have a weird relationship
with each other. Like guys,
I used to spar kickboxing
with those weird relationship,
which I know I was trying
to hurt these guys. Me,
they're breaking my nose and Shit I think
has mentally too because it does hurt.
It doesn't hurt. You know what I'm
saying? Like when you're doing it enough,
you get app out. One of you. One though.
It hurts the ego, but physically, yeah,
but it was like a chap from the
heavyweight light. Turns off, man,
every time you get wrecked, how many
times you've been hitting the bag.
You think about some time that some dude
fucked you up in sparring, just rocked.
You Inspire. You get mad
when you're hitting the bag
like you, you want revenge.
It's totally different.
Yeah,
the scores that got settled even
subconsciously when they spa,
oh he wants more one or the Indians out.
We don't get Tequila out for us. Got It.
That's actually a very valuable knife
that was given to me by Justin Wren.
How was he? Got It from some people in
the Congo because we built wells for them.
I was actually going to slap him
if he poured me another drink. Oh,
that's what that was about.
Don't drink or I'll stab you with is
the opposite. This move discipline. Hey,
you know for black belts,
we've been through this already.
Speaking up being a few virtual
reality, you went to fight.
It doesn't really work.
If you're a virtual reality,
somebody cause you don't get hurt. What
if they use taser technology in with it.
So as you got hit, you got
taste. You know what man,
you virtual reality doesn't work
because it doesn't hurt. But God damn,
it's good for drilling. I've only done
it with boxing. I only did it once.
It's kind of weird because like,
you know like if you look at gloves,
like if you're, you're looking
at your gloves in front of you.
Like if you think of,
you have your hands like this,
that's how the gloves will look. But
it's not, the gloves are like this.
So you hold your hands like this.
So you're in front of the guy and you
find yourself throwing punches like this
because you want your, your wants your
fist to look like an actual pipes.
It's a little odd like that. Like they got
to Polish that up. But other than that,
when the guy hits you, you see a
flash of light. That's not enough.
It's not enough. But it's
interesting. But it's interesting,
like a little bit of a Zap.
Yeah.
But it's far as like just
developing your skills.
It's feedback and really that's all
you need is feedback and then you would
figure out a way to get so good at
the game and get your head movements.
So on point,
it's this virtual guy could never hit
you and your skills would be super sharp.
Then you could move into another stage
of it so that you wouldn't have like
there's one of the things that's a big
problem with teaching people at a strike
is the panic of getting hit.
Like you can look great on pads,
but then when you're actually sparring
there's a panic of getting hit.
So how do you get a
person passed that panic?
Well you got to get them to spa light and
you've got to get them to trust people
and develop their skills so that as
the punch comes, you're not locking up.
Cause some fucking Francis and Ghana dude,
his throne nuclear missiles at your dome.
No,
someone's just touching you and
you get to learn to do it that way.
You can do that virtually and
you can't do with everything.
It's not going to work with
Jujitsu because it's too
much moving and scrambling.
And chunking down and you feel them.
But what you don't,
what you don't have is uh,
you, you like, you don't,
it's going to be difficult to like throw
kicks, like kicks are going to be weird.
Like maybe you could do that.
We'd have to have something on your legs.
Soldiers or military does where they try
to mimic it through computers and then
he,
they tried to the exact t and put them
in stressful situations and then when the
bullets are real really firing a
lot of them, it's when it's real,
there's nothing that can do.
It helps for sure.
It didn't hurt to play one of those games
in Afghanistan where they gave us like
rifles and you had noise and video.
They mimic so stressful.
You get so pumped,
but it's still a video game.
It's just not the navy seals delta.
He's like even we do all that and
then even when the real blows Flan,
I'll look right in behind me and the
guys just frozen because it's real.
He knows the consequences problem.
The big problem with the virtual reality
boxing thing is you're actually not
hitting anything like you need to
practice. So my ideas is crazy.
No wait,
it's okay.
I'm telling you that a man like a
robot on some kind of thing that gets
controlled like this and he moved,
there's a row,
you're actually boxing of robot chicken.
You've got balloons,
he's got actual balloons for fifth with
powder on it. Somebody else's contract,
get a bunch of blue powder all over.
You know what I mean?
So you're boxing got balloons for hands.
So you gotta like hit Shit. And you know,
they did
it was actually doing it like a real
will be the wolverine played on the actor
Wolverine. They did that
movie off. What are these?
Oh these are these for football kind of
shit and chase after you knock a robot
and they stole your idea. That's
a good idea. But what I'm saying,
yeah, but you know that thing
that I got in my garage, Eddie,
that rubber guy with the,
you know,
it's just a torso and you
could combination box on them,
have something like that with arms throw.
Yeah,
you give him a bone on the upper arm,
you know, you give him some rigid,
rigid rigidity, but then the
lower arms for the forums down,
you just have it as just a rough
issue you could do with the robot.
Just the words it,
it's just a robot and you just got to
program it to go down and you can teach
them this James
to shoulder roll.
If you can avoid the robot. It's
not like a real fight, but damn,
it's pretty damn close.
You're avoiding these combos that are
prone programmed in by nerds down the
wing. Chung dummy with some rudimentary
concept related to that. No,
because it didn't move, but this
lesson to start with now movement,
you start with an object and then late,
everybody moved telling you
this virtual reality thing is,
is really there's somebody,
it doesn't matter because it's you're,
you're moving and you're shadow boxing.
There's a lot of shadow boxing.
You're not hitting your thing,
but you're visualizing this
time you're visualizing,
but something's in front of you.
And when you hit it,
it's head snaps back and you can move
away from shots and dig to the bottom line
is better. But I liked that one.
That one. Could you get your,
you're buying the idea.
The two of them are might together
and that's going to happen.
Get Elon Musk on it.
Like mix
mass on it. I have celebrities.
Ilan calling about a fight.
We call him Brian. I'll let you know. I
must give you one. I'll give up. Yeah,
call him back. He bought a Tesla.
You get a, you get a phone call.
One phone with the car.
Yeah, I'm a celebrity. I'm
fucking on TV. I saw that, uh,
Mickey Garcia fight that you
were telling me about it. Mike,
your Mickey Mikey Garcia.
He was telling me for an hour 36 and oh,
it was a horrible knockout. How
bad. I thought that guy died it,
but it took two minutes to get them up.
And Garcia.
He took like a couple of years off
because of um, promotional problems.
They got problems in MMA and boxing that
are real similar that way where they
tied up with promoters
and shift goes down.
But there's so many promoters in boxing.
You got the Goossens, you got Bob Arum,
you got, you know, fucking
Floyd Mayweather productions,
the money team to get out of Globe
and has his own Canelo has his own,
I'll have some promotions.
They're starting to like branch out
because he's worked with golden boy.
But he does have his own
promotion to the UFC.
If I was at UFC and I just spent $4
billion to buy the UFC and all this shit
starts going down, I'd be
like, you mother fuckers,
do you know how long it's gonna take to
make back that $4 billion with you guys
all holding a big ranch and off
and start your own promotions. But,
but that's why. That's why your salad
now sell again. No. Why they salt?
Yeah, those guys. Fuck yeah,
they know what look the Renzo is
his genius and long right time.
These guys are cause before
when Lorenza was there,
people felt like they know the
motherfucking fucking Godfather.
He was right there. He was the guy.
He's whatever decision the Renzo wanted.
I mean you've got frank right there too,
but whatever decision the Renzo wanted,
it was just done. No questions. Boom.
So everyone felt loyal to that,
you know,
and like you don't want to fucking leave.
You know what I mean?
This is the Godfather. You know what I
mean? Now it's like who owns the UFC?
We didn't know one. You don't know those
guys. Yeah, but here's the thing, man.
It's far as the UFC got for in two to up
to 2017 nobody anticipated up til 2005
even in 2005 nobody saw that coming.
But then the first episode of the
first ever ultimate fire EHRs,
and then it becomes a huge superstar
event with Stephan Bonner versus Forrest
Griffin and the files, millions of
people tune in, the world explodes.
MMA becomes popular. And then here
we are, 12 years later looking at it,
nobody saw this. If they can keep
going like that. See that's the thing.
Painted exponential growth.
You don't anticipate it.
These guys like scurry and super bore.
These guys like Yahya, Rodriguez,
volunteers, all these Frances and
got all these new superstructure,
Conor Mcgregor,
these new superstars emerging,
this shit could be twice
as big five years from now.
It's like your positive attitude.
Positive about this.
I'm saying I love it.
No one's more bullish on MMA than me.
I think it should be the biggest sport
in the world. Yeah. I think it's the mom,
the one that transcends boundaries.
It transcends cultures and races.
It makes sense. If a guy
dunks a basketball in your
face, at the end of the day,
the only saving grace is a pitch. I
will find you outside. No, fuck you up.
But if you fuck somebody, I got
some guy up and he goes, oh,
I can still dunk a basketball on you.
Nobody gives a shit.
It's the end all be all of
sports is the super aggro. Yes.
It's almost not even as a girl.
Yes. Not even super aggro.
It's more impressive than anything.
If someone wins some crazy us open
tennis tournament and that's an amazing
thing.
If Conor McGregor knocks Floyd Mayweather
the fuck out with a piston like left
hand,
it might not happen, but if it
did, the world explodes too.
But anyone can [inaudible]
you can join us.
Not In the NBA, not in the NFL. You can.
It's married but it can fight in the UFC.
Cm punk pumpkin. It's the Ross
Forum. Brenton shops cheese.
He gets Moody's morning.
So Nigga,
you don't have much more
impressive in his I'll Lebron James
Caan team. Absolutely. Come on. Does
that more impressive? Oh my God.
Destroying another man.
That's the most impressive shit come food.
Pure Mba
[inaudible] up another dude,
man.
I'm telling.
I'm saying that what you did is the most
the of shit and what you did not being
in a team and be like,
whoa. Not athletically. It's
the ball in the hole. He's a
moose. Makes me do it again. What
makes that bat? The ball goes in
the hole being you're being a,
what's the word and insider.
Cerios Joe's hit the ball with the racket
at a hundred miles an hour ago.
We just got,
we just got done looking at this field
full of baseball players early going,
he'll pull watches that
stupid fucking game.
And I enjoy watching baseball. Hitting a
home run. It's the hardest thing to do.
And professionals,
you're a contrarian.
It's not even close to the hardest thing
to do. The hard knock knockout, Josie,
all the with one punch, 13 seconds and
after you talk shit about him for a year,
the odds are higher hitting a baseball.
Shut the fuck up Jimmy Burke.
Imagine baseball fight companions.
Imagine how bad that would pick that.
Hey,
I can pay to watch the Dodgers
with the reds be awesome.
Baseball fight companion. We have amazing
cause we'd be drunk and high as fuck.
And I'm like just be
like a ceremonial thing.
We don't actually watch the game.
We just put it on.
I can guarantee you there
are baseball companions.
What do we need to do?
It's a NASCAR fight companion
or WWE. Nascar. Bet some serious money.
I'm telling you guys,
these all exist.
They called him second screen experiences
in every sport now is doing them every
day
after Joe
fell has a second screen experience.
They started doing this in the last year.
All of them, the NFL has to sec, they
call it a second screen experience.
Mother fucker.
Hold on.
What's the whole website called like
ramble on or something like to anybody can
get on and make their own companion
for India. They should call John Rules.
That's like chat rooms or
don't. I mean, uh, who else?
Who else was do you never saw someone do
it. You invented it. Here's what I did.
Here's what I did.
I'm the first guy for sure.
That is the lead commentator
for a gigantic organization,
like a professional sports organization
that also does a thing on the internet
where they smoke weed and talk
shit watching the same way.
[inaudible]
you're the only ones.
If they can cuss,
wouldn't that be cool?
Joe could just because people have said
that for years and now you're actually
doing, but here's the crazy
thing. He's faking companions. Get
more downloads than any
broadcast and views. Yes.
They get as much downloads is a major
Fox card on a major Fox UFC world
championship card.
That's how many downloads he seeks care
we're, we're closing in this month on,
we're probably, what are we at right now,
Jamie?
I checked before.
We're going to get close to 85 million
for the month. That's for Youtube? No,
that's for iTunes. Just
iTunes and then youtube is how
much point? 2 million. Yeah.
Can you ask yourself why
they're watched so much?
Not just keeps [inaudible]
at a million views.
A way more way more than what you got
super drunk with Cameron Hanes tower
seven. That's when it's like
5 million. What's it at?
600,000 no.
Well what is it on the audio
is the last firing cap.
We did almost 6 million downloads
a serious Eddie. Your recap, Eddie.
That's after the fight. The
recap, the 6 million downloads.
He's got one word on iTunes.
It's talking about youtube though.
When the youtube is not as much. Youtube
is only like, well, what percentage?
How many views per episode? Percent.
20% of the nobody. How many views?
Like what is merely average
visa lately for that? That's it.
Like 5 million for audio about
weighing up to 1 million for you.
Two videos like it depends on the show.
1 million when you and I are on
with Alex Jones, which will buy,
but by the way be episode nine 11 dude,
I'm working so hard and make an episode
nine 11 I'm doing so many goddamn
episodes just like just so I can get
to number nine 11 with Alex Jones.
That's Wednesday, right
Wednesday. Alex Jones,
how huge cascade and be home shit.
And it's going to be episode nine 11 and
that's what I'm going to keep my mouth
shut. I'm going to keep going
to ask you a fun. First of all,
we're not doing it sober, so don't even
try. It's going to get weird. Come on,
let him,
he's not going to be sober either.
I just want to maybe ask a
question or two but I'm going to,
we're going to house shut.
We're going have not gonna say anything
like the Flintstones Jones. I love him.
Love. Does he smell queen? Uh,
neither can confirm nor deny.
Even if you don't,
if you're in this room,
you're smoking weed or
whether you like it or not,
you're taking a contact
high of epic proportion.
I walked in and smelled it right away.
Alex Jones is going to,
that Shell might break records. It's
going to be interesting. Come on.
Cause would be bigger than lands.
Armstrong.
Any what's your big bigger than Atlanta.
So I'm showing what's one of
your questions you wanna ask him.
Don't say don't give it away
cause it prepare for it.
You gotta sneak it up on them. The weird
thing about conspiracy horse that make,
that are making a living off
conspiracy theories is, is uh,
there are so many conspiracy theories
and a lot of guys are just like into one
or two and they're experts or ninth or
experts on JFK and they fucking know
everything about this. It's so deep
and so sophisticated and complicated.
The whole JFK thing,
all the theories and all what could have
happened and all that. It's so deep,
dude, spend their whole life on that.
So when they talk to dudes are, are,
are, are still believing in CNN
and they're trying to convert them,
try to wake them up a little bit.
What ends up happening is there,
they've invested so much money
in JFK that they can't, uh,
they're not even looking at other ways.
We're getting fucked because then
they deny all that other shit.
So when other people bring like
other crazy conspiracy theories up,
they got to say, that dude's a shill.
He's tall. He's right about the JFK shit.
Cause I know cause I studied that, but
all this other shit he's talking about,
that's got to be a shield.
So it's good to know you,
Eddie Lee Harvey Oswald Killed Jfk.
Everybody,
let me finish what I'm saying real quick.
Everybody thinks not everybody,
there's a lot of conspiracy theories
out there that are experts in certain
conspiracies that they think Alex
Jones is a shill because he's not,
what is that? A vacuum? Some crazy.
Anyways, the ground, let me send
this, this road's creamy finishes.
So there's guys out there, ouch. I'm
going to be on the Goddamn show Wednesday.
And there's a lot of conspiracy.
There's that think he's a shill because
they're not talking about the conspiracy
theory that they spent all their
time on. Like Alex Jones is like, I,
you know what, there's, there's
different levels of transparency
as a generalist and a specialist
in everything and a generalist,
the specialists can go deeper
in their one specialty.
Then any generalist conspiracy theorists
argue with each other more than with
skeptics. It's incredible. Like the
scene, everybody's pointing things.
He's a shill.
He's the show.
Just cause they're not spending time or
promoting your, like Alex Jones, he's,
he's into certain conspiracy theories
and it's, uh, it's like, you know,
he's got his plan,
his agenda to wake people up or whatever,
whatever he thinks he's got his
plan. And then this guy's had, has,
this is how we do it. This guy walk, come,
you're not talking about what they're
doing and how come you're not talking
about the Jews.
Conspiracy theories are accusing each
other of being scheels all the time
because they're not like Alex
Jones has his own agenda.
I don't know. That happens in every little
sub culture though. Like in fighting,
uh, you know, certain people,
he's going to try to change
the subject here to fighting.
And I'm not going to let you know it
was going to say that's exactly why you
start to get news sources
that are credible.
So what happens is don't
talk about credible sources.
The economist, how many years can you
look up? How many years old? The economy,
it's over a hundred years old. And
so the kind of narrow, well hold on,
why does eight, why does it
magazine stay there? Well,
because what happens is if they start
posting news, people will read it and say,
that must be true.
When it starts not being true,
people will stop reading that newspaper
or that magazine. This was bullshit.
So that's why certain news organizations
develop a reputation team 43 God,
hold on. It's been, there you go.
So what happens is you can't fool
people that long. Okay, Carol,
while Eddie after a while and
he called us. No, no, no Eddie,
you've got to let them. Teddy. The
economist is a very credible source.
And if it wasn't, they would get
found out not only by people like you,
but also by other news. Okay,
hold on, hold on, hold on.
Hold the other news outlets.
Heady. You let them talk and then I
got a question for you about this.
So there are,
there are credible sources
of news which you adhere to.
I know you do.
And the question becomes,
what is the criteria by which
you can trust a news source?
A company that promotes news,
that reports news.
There has to be a vetting process.
And what I'm saying is that you develop
a reputation after a while because it's
pretty easy to find out if you've been
lying for a 140 years about every news
story.
Yeah.
So what happens is you start that you
have to get your news from somewhere,
right?
You have to rely on it somewhere.
So what they do is they get people
who are investigative journalists.
When you have, what if you had a news
organization where you'd say is you'd say,
I want three,
four,
maybe six different credible
sources before I print this.
I would imagine you'd be that way. Right?
Right. Uh, uh, people who actually, yeah,
so people who corroborate the same
story and they have independent lines of
either inquiry or investigation, whatever
it might be. And that's kind of how,
and that's why I invest in reading,
not just the New York Times,
but the economist,
two sides of the political spectrum,
NPR.
And when I hear three publications like
that, that a one that's independent,
one that, that gets, it relies on
like a public sourcing, not, not, uh,
not private sourcing. After awhile
they're all reporting the same news story.
There's gotta be some truth to it.
The CIA has infiltrated
all mainstream media.
You are being pumped.
Okay. But hold on a second.
Here's a question. I'm not
saying stop. Stop. What do
you know about the economist?
Um, I know that if it's
mainstream media, it's, it's,
if there anything for me,
the mainstream media is controlled
by the government. Okay.
But you understand that
anything that the mains,
all the mainstream media all agrees
on and anything that they're pushing,
I am automatically seriously skeptical
about it because our government has lied
to us for Millennia.
Changed thing may say,
I understand you're saying
it. I'm not trusting. I know,
I understand what you're saying,
but you really don't have any information
to go on based on the, uh, when you,
when you talk about this
particular magazine,
you don't know anything about,
I'm not an expert in the economist,
but I'm pretty sure,
I guess I'm going,
I'm pretty sure its own buy I understand.
You have to understand is
happening is happening.
Having a prejudice, dismissive attitude
without having actually examined
it is part of the whole problem we have
with information. The first place. Right.
You might be right,
but you haven't examined it and
you're already throwing it away.
But before ever looking into it at all,
it's a giant,
it's a giant issue because there's people
that are worth billions and billions
of dollars. They're getting their
financial information from somewhere.
Where's it coming from?
Are they sharing it with each other
and then eating babies and fucking each
other?
Like what are they doing?
Or are they getting it
from a longstanding,
credible source that all these
different super rich people rely upon?
And that's why it's
critical. No, but Eddie,
you don't know if it's untrue,
but you're prejudging it and
that's not healthy either.
That's one of the reasons why a lot of
these conspiracy theories fall apart is
because there hasn't been any forethought
into concoctions. Let me speak,
just immediately step in and say, if
it's mainstream, it's gotta be this,
this is this. When you have a, uh,
let's just say a criminal
who's been in jail,
who's been in jail for
uh, uh, credit card fraud.
He's just a shit bag. Does one
person, yeah, just one dude. One Dude.
Just a shit bag. Criminal
credit card, fraud, robbery.
Go ahead. Are you going to
believe these guys bad? This guy,
but he's not a person that's not the
government they began with the economist,
you know,
is not really connected to the government.
I'm not an expert in the
economist. I understand, but
that assumption is negative.
It's not smart to assume that you might
be smart. You have to trust criminals,
trust.
But you're not talking about criminals.
You're talking about a long standing
magazine that's dedicated to explain the
economy and very pragmatic terms.
Mainstream media is criminal,
but he made that decision.
But there's nothing that could be
criminal when you don't eat something
that the state has a long history of
credit fraud and robbery.
Is there anything that can tell you that
comparison, this piece, and the economist
gets everything wrong. Look at this,
but this is one of the reasons why is he
criticized? But this is a [inaudible].
Put that in context please.
Can I put that in?
So Steve Forbes is a Republican and
very, very right way. So what he,
what he's all he's doing is he
is budding Obama's point of view,
right?
And now let's,
let's point out that Obama is not an
economist and Obama probably got an
honorary position as a journalist to
post this thing. That's how it works.
So the economist is not about, it's
not economists that right. It is it.
The economist says, hey, write a piece.
And what they'll have is they'll have an
op ed piece. They, they, they, so you can,
yeah. So when you can write
something, if your Obama,
the economists will allow you to be
sort of the, a featured, uh, opinion,
what's the date on those? That's why they
call it her. Not that this was November.
So it's an opinion editorial, right?
Is that right? Yeah, it's an bad,
so when you eat it,
it's criticized by people who
disagree with the New York Times.
The back of the newspaper
every, every, every day is an op Ed page,
which is different. Various journalists,
some right wing most left wing who give
their point of view on the world and not
so much like,
uh,
cause a lot of like Nicholas Christoff
was in there working with women in Kenyan
schools and stuff or, or the, or slate.
Uh, I'm sorry, a forced prostitution.
This is an investigative journalist
not making any money by the way,
but he's in there.
And what he'll do is write an op Ed piece
that will bring your awareness to the
fact that for example in Cambodia there's
a lot of sex for sale and it's really
horrible et, et Cetera. So you know
it's worth giving the New York Times.
It's worth giving. The economist
is worth getting MPR a fair shake.
You might learn something cause
to say that it's all lies.
Eddie is a little extreme and also
they wouldn't be in business if,
because people don't like to be fooled
and I don't think you can fool people all
the time. Good. Full. Okay.
That's the way I see it.
I mean I you've been had by the CIA
operation mockingbird you've been had but
wait a minute, you just, as your
know, I don't blame you, you up.
We're trying to get indoctrinated.
What if you've been indoctrinated by
Europe by the ideas that you're exposed to
it because what I want you to guys, you're
identical. You both put on dot. Yeah.
You both been indoctrinated with
ideas both that are separate.
Both that are probably wrong because most
of the information we get is not based
in truth. Your own point. Not Most.
I didn't give you an idea what I
just said was how I get my news,
which is from several different
sources. I'm with Ya. Who are,
who are one who doesn't. One is not not
run by a profit motive what like NPR,
national public radio that relies on
contributions from its listeners like me.
So,
okay.
And then you've got the New York Times
leftwing I disagree with a lot of it all
the time. Then you've got,
then you've got the economist,
then you've got time magazine.
All competing. By the way,
we're all competing for the story.
So to say that I am, I'm in,
I had the same doctors.
Well I'm sorry,
your fundamental beliefs are based on
what you've learned and been exposed to.
Well, hold on and I will
dilate on that because what I,
what I'm exposed to varies.
It's,
I try to be as well rounded as I can.
And if that is being closed minded,
I would like to hear what would
be considered open mind. No, no,
I just mean all of your beliefs.
Many of which much more of yours
that I believe with that Ed, he said,
no offense Eddie, I love you. Um,
are based on everything
you've learned in your life,
all the things you've been exposed
to this and my emotion too.
Emotion built you a beliefs. Astrology,
let's just built you a belief system.
Just as Edy's has add,
he's everything.
He's been exposed to everything that
needs to learn to all the information.
Not just the information you're talking
about, but how you learn information,
how you gather ideas. All of those have
built you guys your own belief systems.
And when you look at each other,
you're just shocked at the other one.
Can't see you're shocked at the other one.
Can't see your belief system,
but he's just like you.
He has one of his own that are structured
and built upon every experience he's
had in his whole life. And he is sure
that everything he's saying is right.
Just as you both on,
it's a good second and you bolt.
Neither of you can see that this
other guy just can't understand.
Cause I know the truth. And he does. Isn't
that great? That's how I feel. But yet,
and that's how he feels
and that's how he feels.
And that's what's going on
in North America and all
over the world. How I feel,
I don't think that's fair to compare
the [inaudible]. I don't think so.
What I think is what I see
with Eddie is that he has so,
so we all want to believe that we're
responsive to evidence. Getty does ideas.
We won't belong to be there were
scientific and in that we'd have our mind
changed based on the evidence,
but he can't change your mind and
you can't change his mind. But, but,
but that's not true. That's not, that's
not a character resisting to me at all.
I changed my mind all the time
based on the evidence now,
right now,
uh,
well I sent Eddie several sort of
what could be considered conspiracy,
but they were, they were reported by
mainstream. Some of the stuff was,
and you remember that we
were talking about recently,
I can't remember what type of
text message. No, no, no, no, no.
This was something else. Yeah. And
it was a real one. Oh, it was fast.
Glenn Greenwald's article
in the Guardian about the,
the government turning on Donald Trump
substantiated reports,
clock political operatives hiring,
you know, x intelligence officers
to discredit a candidate.
And this is happening and this
is what the biggest fear is.
What do we believe at this point we'll
all the fake news and we have to be very,
very vigilant about.
And so when I formulated an opinion,
one of the great things about doing a
podcast is I'm found out all the time to
be wrong. I love that point
of view. And I'll be like,
I'll say something and people will
be like, Hey, by the way, bullshit,
because here's this, this, and I go, Geez,
that's embarrassing. I was wrong on that.
Great to be wrong,
just to get new information.
So we have to all be willing to set that.
First of all,
I don't think all the people in
mainstream media or criminal, but you do.
I don't see any evidence for that entity.
I do see that sometimes
mainstream media is discredited.
I do see sometimes that
they make mistakes.
I do sometimes see sometimes like rolling
stone articles gets it really wrong.
And there are examples of course, of
mainstream media where they get it wrong.
Sometimes they get it wrong very badly,
but I have to believe is that in a
lot of times they get it right? Yeah.
Because I mean,
just take a couple of things,
like if they're reporting on the war in
Syria and how many children are killed
and you see that you see pictures and
you see video of children crying in a
hospital,
it's just not the same when
you're that Eddie, Eddie, Eddie,
you've got to stop doing that because
you're just trying to discredit what his
ideas are by making jokes about
it or mopping in or show. But no,
you're munching your mocking and knew
you were mocking earlier saying you don't
believe it's how you indoctrinated.
You were telling him that he's,
he's brainwashed.
You were telling them that you're
mocking it instead of just having an open
conversation about the
possibilities. My point, although I,
I'm probably 75%, uh, think like Brian,
we all are just thinking
all of the information that
we've ever been exposed to
and we've built up a belief
system based on everybody has.
And when our belief systems don't mix,
we have a problem.
And that's the problem that I think Eddie
actually believes that wholeheartedly.
Yeah.
Mocking his thoughts by saying,
you're brainwashed, you're brainwashed.
Brainwashed. But he didn't say,
you're brainwashed. You've, you've said
it many times. What do you, what do you,
what is your expression then? Because
that's what I'm doing is paraphrasing.
What am I saying? You? Yeah, exactly.
You say he's written [inaudible]
it's not a rational debate,
the situation, and you really
don't know anything harsher than it
worked on you.
You're saying he's brainwashed in
responding to what you're mocking him by
saying that, you know, you're right,
but it's not the way we figure things out.
It's just not because it's like
all of a sudden you pick teams,
everybody tries to win. Look, I
did it a good chunk of my life.
It's just not the way to communicate.
It's a constant way that people do it
because nobody ever wants to be wrong.
And when you, when you get into
debates and becomes a mind a game,
as much as it becomes a conversation,
I'm saying that's really bad for everybody
and that it's really just like if you,
if you're still in it,
if you know your side is losing and you
know you don't have any facts on your
side and you're still in it,
you're fucking it up for everybody else.
But if you make sense, if you make
sense then you don't need all that you,
you know it worked on you, you're
a, you're a fucking brainwash.
You don't need all that.
If your,
if your facts are in line and if you've
done exhaustive research on the subject
and a lot when you just blanket throw
all mainstream media is CIA operation
mockingbird nine 11 was an inside job.
Chem trails got to go out
and actually billion babies.
So we're trying to solve problems
you meet. And so one of the problems,
like for example, healthcare, universal
healthcare, gun control, these things,
it's very, when you get into it,
it's really difficult to come in.
And we were talking with,
Joe and I were talking about this.
You can't know everything.
Control. Look at this right here.
Here's some conspiracy shit that's real.
Another Glenn Greenwald polled Washington
Post is richly rewarded for false news
about Russia threat while
public is deceived. Wow.
And Glenn Greenwald who
exposed Wiki leaks. Of course,
he's the guy who was the reason why
he works for the Washington
Post right now. He's, he has a,
an investigative journalist. These
are the kind of guys I love. No,
he doesn't work for the Washington
Post's investigative journalist. So he,
Post supported by somebody who has the
Washington Post. Who is he?
Who, no, he's The Guardian.
The Guardian is essentially a British
leftwing mainstream news source.
But this is a classic
example. Now Eddie, he just,
he just exposed what would be considered
a conspiracy now and he's just,
the guy did the thing about Donald Trump.
But I mean,
I'm saying, I'm saying, but this is a very
good example. This is an investigation,
but I do, I do believe
that, uh, I do believe that,
but he's on the payroll of the Guardian.
Some guys,
some guys are are jumping ship and,
and doing the right thing,
but he's the reason why Edward Snowden
got all that information out. That guy,
Glenn Greenwald,
I remember he works for a
[inaudible] body is a psychotic.
Not Everybody is down with the program.
Some people are like,
they're coming forward. There's whistle
blowers but Obama, but he's not a whistle.
He gets paid by the Guardian, you know,
legit journal. Some guys are legit,
never said, oh, I'm suspect
of all. I understand.
I believe, but he's mainstream. This guy
is mainstream as a get some mainstream,
all mainstream stuff. For me,
I, I'm skeptical but some, some,
I didn't say everything was false, just
some, some guys are growing a conscious,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with Eddie being skeptical. No.
Journalism journalism is
based on being skeptical.
Michael Shermer is a skeptic.
You being a skeptic means I need,
you told me something now I need to trust.
Is it fun?
Was it three or five or six or between
three and six but the bottom line is you
should always be a spa skeptic as our
credible news sources because they say,
what was the news? What was the story?
What are you saying? Okay, I need sources.
I as the editorial,
as the,
as the editor in chief or whoever
it is who okays these things,
I have got to see tangible,
measurable proof,
which is why the rhinestones story
about the Uva case was such a big deal.
Now because they printed this story
was a made up story about rape,
about a gang rape that never took place.
No, there's no sexual assault history.
There was,
it was not real.
It was all fake and they printed it and
they printed it because they didn't want
to ask the hard questions because it
dealt with something that was a taboo
subject,
sexual assault,
and they liked that as a catastrophic
failure of journalism. These,
these checks and balances are in place
to make sure that we know the fucking
truth when it gets printed in
such a prestigious magazine
is a rolling stone and
it gets dealt with right now.
It's still going on. Yes.
Let me ask you say get, they get
found out. Look at Brian Williams.
They get found out.
They get found out by their own,
within their own organizations. They got
find out our scientists and professors,
uh, is there a history of them being
bought and paid for some of them?
Hold on a second. Let me,
let me, let me qualify that.
There have been tens of
millions of scientists over
the course of human history.
There have been a small handful that
have been corrupt and those small handful
that had corrupted,
we have found
out about the results
have been catastrophic.
What they've done has been horrific.
What they did with the sugar industry,
what they did with tobacco,
what they did with,
there's a lot of fucking now
the environmental catastrophes
that were downplayed
by scientists.
There have been some bought and paid
scientists 100% but that's just like
there's certain people that
are going to be corrupt.
The vast majority applied to the rules
of science. Dedicate that. Right.
So do you think that it's possible that
journalists are bought and paid for some
of them? There's absolutely
proof of that. That's why.
That's why you gotta be skeptical.
Like I don't know which one you want.
You can be bought.
But Eddie smart,
that's way not in a paranoid hiding
in a fucking corner. No, but Eddie,
you guys are full of Shit.
I love you.
But when you're talking about something
like the economist that you don't have
any information about it all set,
then you blanketly dismissed them.
That is where, that's where
it all started from. I said,
I don't know anything about the economist,
but it's mainstream media and if
they're speaking the same thing,
everyone else is spewing
like CNN and see and
listen. That's just the way I am, dude.
That's just the way that
they compete with these.
I'm not saying you should be that way.
I'm just saying, Hey, listen, you know,
I try to help people. I said, listen,
you're being fucking honey dick.
You're being punked lake up.
I tried to do that,
but I'm not going to go crazy with it
after awhile. Zoned by the Rothschilds.
Well, can't shock me now
that doesn't shock me that,
I mean it's a public company is Cadbury,
the Kennedy people and they make
great public has done by Rothschild
to public means anybody shot.
So that's what I'm saying.
I'm saying when it's coming,
when, when scientists and uh,
professors have been bought and paid for
like big ones, like Ivy League schools,
like Yale scientist says this,
Harvard professor says this to push
some agenda or it could happen.
And then there's, you know, and then
operation mockingbird, you kind of, you,
you can't ignore that,
you know about it through
mainstream media. I'm just saying,
I don't know who's who and I'm just
getting wine. I don't know who's who.
And I know one, this is for
me, this is just me. For me,
I'm 100% convinced the moon landings were
faked. You don't have to believe that.
There's no proof that the earth is flat,
but don't book until she,
but no, no, no, don't you. But that guy,
hey listen,
there is no proof that the earth is flat
where all the pictures of earth from
space,
CGI is ended by NASA.
It's the way our satellite stage
Johnson [inaudible] about flat earth is.
I want to hear it so I'm
just going to flat out
no. Why do you know why it's a
perspective issue. Do you know that? Why?
That's why they pieced together the
pictures of the earth because it's a
perspective issue based. The earth
is fucking gigantic space station.
You're not far enough away
to get the full earth and
the bottom line when you should
miss as you want to take a chance.
We would watch every space document or
even can we look and had all this series,
the universe put one to 12 we
were so into it. I was stolen.
I would watch these star documentaries
all they just get every now and then I'd
watch it and I think it is weird
that we're watching 100% CGI,
like everything we're watching
because there's no actual footage,
but that's because they don't have
the capability to fill it out.
Know the names of the scientists.
I don't know the name of the
astronomer or the astrophysicist,
but somebody figured this out.
They got something out there
taking radiation question.
Here's what I'm saying is what I'm saying
real quick, real quick or a flatter.
So when you look at the stars every night,
the Orion
rush donor talk, dude, that's all. This
is definitely not stoner talk question.
There's a question kind of like every
night we look up at the stars and we see
that the belt, that Orion belt
and we see that that north, Yup.
You see that Shit, right? Right. Do it
tonight. You and me holding the everyone.
Isn't that weird? Okay. Let's say
this is the sun right here. Let's say,
look man, I don't know why
this is pissing people off,
but this is the sun and the earth.
[inaudible] figured out any
question. I just want to ask
Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ.
This is make fun of me with this.
Here's the setup, here's the earth,
and it takes a year to go around.
We spin around,
that's mainstream everybody.
And then we got mercury and Venus
and Mars and Saturn out here.
So they're all going to Dallas. And the
solar system, according to mainstream,
is that like a plain Wall Street son's
going around the Goddamn the earth is
spinning a thousand miles an hour and
it's going around the sun like 60,000
miles an hour. And then the sun's
going around the fucking black hole,
like 900,000 miles,
something like that.
So it takes a year for the son, for the
earth to go around. Yeah, it's huge.
It takes a year. So right here is
January and then right here, June, right.
So when the sun is facing,
when we're facing the sun,
it's daylight. And then when we
spin this way, it's nighttime.
So when it's nighttime,
the sun is over here and we're
looking at this side of the space.
We're looking at this side of the space,
right?
There's Orion belt that north star
every fucking night. It's there.
By the time we get to June over,
like when we're looking at this,
this side of the universe,
what the fuck is on the other side?
Why don't you read some books
and get into it? No, no, no, no. I don't
want it. Don't hold us here hostage. No.
See these crazy questions. Listen,
you guys are still what I'm saying?
Why after you need to
tie somebody figured out.
I don't know what it is,
but somebody figured it out.
It's just a question. Well,
Eddie,
I don't know.
The answer does is on the other
and when in six months when the,
when earth gets over here,
why is it still the same
and different areas,
but you want to guy hold
on a second all the time.
Do you understand that it's not.
There's a procession of the equinoxes.
There's a cycle and this cycle of
thousands of years they've mapped out.
They know exactly.
There's a wobble to the earth.
There's a changing in
the sky that we look at,
and it's one of the ways that they get
determined when you go back in history
and look at certain things that they
had lined up to certain constellations,
like in Egypt is one of
the ways they lined it up.
They line it up because they understand
that we're looking at a different area
of the sky every night.
It's slightly different and it changes
over the course of thousands a year for
every night. We don't, you
shouldn't miss. It should be,
that should be a completely ready to fly
a plane and you shouldn't miss it when
you shoot a bullet.
Even I think snipers have to take into
account the curvature of the earth.
We're talking about flat. I'm not talking
about that. I'm talking about the stars.
Let's wrap this up. I gotta get out of
here. I really got to get out of here.
I can't do this flat though.
Perfect.